UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
WILL NOW COME TO ORDER.
AFTERNOON EVERYBODY IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITOL BUILDING I ASK THAT ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BE
PRESENT IN THE SENATE CHAMBER SO
WE CAN ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM AND
BEGIN OUR HEARING. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
GALLERY A TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE RIVERS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE. IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE THE PLATE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS ONE ONE.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE.
FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. FOUR SIX SIX
THREE NINE SIX EIGHT FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE ISTOM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
FOR THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY MONITOR
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
BE- YOU. YOU WILL- WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THIS TIME
YOU WILL BE UN MUTED YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE. THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST
BE USED THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR.
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEDIAN SERVICE OR HAVE. THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE WILL BEGIN
NOW- AND I WANT TO SEE- CLERK TO
HAVE A QUORUM YET. OKAY SO IT
FIVE WE CAN BEGIN. BY CALL-
TAKING A ROLL CALL TO ESTABLISH
QUORUM. CLICK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WESSEL PRESENT WESSEL
PRESENTS DOLLY. DOLLY HERE BAKER
. BECKER HERE FOR JUST. PORGES
HERE BRADFORD. BRADFORD HERE DOT
HERE THOUGHT HERE EGGMAN. EIGHT
MEN HERE GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ HERE
BRO. GROWTH HERE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HERE MCGUIRE. MAN
RUBIO. RUBIO PRESENTS STERN.
KERRY HAVE QUORUM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE HAVE SIX BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA- AND SO WE WILL
HEAR FROM OUR OUR FIRST
PRESENTER ON ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE BY SENATOR
ARCHER LET THE A BILL PERTAINING
TO ENERGY APPLIANCES AND LOCAL
REQUIREMENTS FOLLOWING HIS
PRESENTATION WE WILL HAVE TO
ORGANIZE PRESENTERS ON THE BILL.
ARE THOSE THAT I HAVE ON FILE
HERE ARE ANTHONY SAMPSON AND
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT AND SCOTT
WHICH- ARE BOTH SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT AND WE HAVE ONE OF
OPPOSING SPEAKER PIERRE- DO YOU
FORGE. AND I JUST WANT HIM FOR
THOSE IF THEY'RE LISTENING
ONLINE THEY GET- THREE MINUTES
FOR EACH SIDE SO ANTHONY SAMPSON
WILL HAVE A MINUTE AND A HALF
SCOTT WHICH MEN AND A HALF. M.
M. PIERRE THE FORGE WILL HAVE
THREE MINUTES OKAY WILL BEGIN-
WITH SENATOR ARCHER LET THE
WELCOME. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS. TODAY I'M PRESENTED
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN NINETY
THREE WHICH EEKS TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES WITH DECARBONISATION
AND DECARBONISING CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING BUILDINGS BY REQUIRING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO TAKE
CERTAIN FACTORS INTO
CONSIDERATION BEFORE APPROVING
ORDINANCES. THAT WOULD REQUIRE
GAS APPLIANCES TO BE REPLACED
WITH ELECTRIC APPLIANCES.
SPECIFICALLY THIS LEGISLATION
WOULD REQUIRE THE ORDINANCE TO
UNDERGO REVIEW AND APPROVAL BY
THECALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
IF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT DOES OT
PROVIDE FOR EXEMPTIONS IN
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE FOR EXAMPLE
REPLACING APPLIANCES WOULD BE
TECHNICALLY INFEASIBLE OR WOULD
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME CUSTOMERS.
NO REVIEW WOULD BE REQUIRED
HOWEVER IF SUCH EXEMPTIONS ARE
INCLUDED IN THE ORDINANCE. WHEN
IT COMES TO BUILDING
CARBONIZATION CALIFORNIA HAS
LARGELY FOCUSED ON NEW
CONSTRUCTION IN FACT OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS MANY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE ADOPTED WHAT
ARE OFTEN REFERRED TO AS REACH
COACH WHICH ARE LOCAL ENERGY
ORDINANCES REQUIRING MORE
STRINGENT ENERGY REQUIREMENTS
THAN THOSE SET BY THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY. CODE THESE REACH COACH
WHICH ADDRESS NEW CONSTRUCTION
WOULD BE REVIEWED AND APPROVED
BY THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. WELL DECARBONISING
NEW CONSTRUCTION IN CALIFORNIA
IS IMPORTANT THE BIGGEST AREA OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION IS CALIFORNIA'S
NEARLY FOURTEEN MILLION HOMES
AND SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
SQUARE FEET OF COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS. HOWEVER THERE ARE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED
WITH DECARBONISATION AND
DECARBONISING EXISTING BUILDINGS
COMPARED TO NEW BUILDINGS THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
RECENTLY IDENTIFIED COST AS MOST
SIGNIFICANT BERRIER. ORDING TO
THE COMMISSION AND ELECTRIC
PANEL UPGRADE MAY COST BETWEEN
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED AND FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH IS PAID
FOR BY THE HOMEOWNER OR PROPERTY
OWNER IN A SCENARIO IN WHICH
EVERY HOUSE BUILT BEFORE
NINETEEN NINETY REQUIRES AN
ELECTRIC PANEL UPGRADE IT WOULD
COST APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
TO FORTY BILLION DOLLARS. THIS
DOES NOT EVEN INCLUDE THE COST
OF THE APPLIANCE AND
INSTALLATION. THESE COSTS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT LOWER
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THESE COMMUNITIES
FACE ADDITIONAL UNIQUE BARRIERS
BECAUSE OF THIS MEDIC. IN AT
INEQUITY- HISTORY OF LOWER
ACCESS TO CAPITAL AND FINANCING
A GREATER ENERGY BURDEN AND
LOWER RATES OF HOMES OR OR
BUSINESS OWNERSHIP. AMONG OTHER
BARRIERS TO BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION THE COMMISSION
ALSO IDENTIFIED WORKFORCE
TRAINING FOR INSTALLATION AND
MAINTENANCE PRACTICES. AS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS BEGIN ADOPTING
ORDINANCES TO ADDRESS EXISTING
BUILDINGS CALIFORNIA LAW MUST BE
UPDATED TO ENSURE THAT THESE
IDENTIFIED CHALLENGES ARE
CONSIDERED AN ARE UNDER
CONSIDERATION AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND IF NECESSARY AT THE STATE
LEVEL BEFORE SUCH ORDINANCE MAY
TAKE AFFECT. TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE WOULD REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SEEKING TO RE
REQUIRE HOMEOWNERS AND
BUSINESSES AND BUSINESS OWNERS
YOU SWITCH THEIR APPLIANCES FROM
GAS TO ELECTRIC TO CONSIDER
ISSUES LIKE THAT THE CLOCK
TICKED A TECHNICAL. FEASIBILITY
TECHNICAL FEASIBILITY IMPACTS TO
THE WORK FORCE AND IMPACTS TO
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
COMMUNITIES IF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PROVIDES SOME
FLEXIBILITY IN THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES THEN THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
WOULD NOT NEED TO REVIEW THE
ORDINANCE. NOW I WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE. SOMETHING VERY CLEAR TO
THE COMMITTEE. I BELIEVE THAT
DECARBONIZATION AND
DECARBONIZING CALIFORNIA'S
BUILDING IS A CRITICAL COMPONENT
OF OUR OVERALL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS REDUCTION EFFORTS I
ALSO BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE YOU
THERE ARE EXTRAORDINARY YOUR
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
WITH THIS. AND I WANT CAL TO BE
SUCCESSFUL HOWEVER WE MUST ALSO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN TO OUR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THAT MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO HANDLE THESE ORDINANCES WHICH
IS WHY WE NEED THE STATE TO BE
INVOLVED I HEAD OF THE ADOPTION.
ORDINANCES FOR THAT REASON I
BELIEVE THE STATE HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY AND A ROLE TO
PLAY IN ENSURING THAT CHART THAT
THE TRANSITION TO T. TWO
DECARBONISATION TO DECARBONISING
BUILDINGS IS DONE LOGICALLY IN A
RESPONSIBLE NOT PORTABLE WAY. TO
THIS END I AM OPEN TO FEEDBACK
FOR MY COLLEAGUES THE CHAIR AND
I WILL LOOK FORWARD TO ANY
ADDITIONAL- AMENDED GOING WITH
THIS NOPE. AND I ASKED. FOR KERN
CAN WORK SEVEN AND TO NEST. AND
BUT IT WILL WORK FOR A PATH OF
SUCCESS BY EVERYONE. WITH THIS
**** WITH ME TODAY THAT'S BEHALF
THIS IMPORT BILL I HAVE A HARD.
THE GOAL OF KELP YOU TOO BOYS.
MS YOU HAVE TO THE A. O. SMITH
CORP RISK AFTER I VOTE AND I YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THIS WILL BEGIN
WITH ANTHONY'S BEFORE WE DO I
JUST WANTED TO ASK YOU TO
CLARIFY YOUR COMMENTS THAT YOU
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS YES SIR OKAY VERY
WELL UP THE WILL MOVE TO A
SPEAKER IN SUPPORT MEN AND A
HALF ANTHONY SAMPSON. AB ANTHONY
SAMPSON HERE SAMPSON ADVISORS ON
BEHALF OF A. O. SMITH
CORPORATION. ALONG WITH ITS
WHOLLY OWNED SUBSIDIARIES AO
SMITH IS THE LARGEST
MANUFACTURER AND SELLER OF
RESIDENTIAL AND COMMERCIAL WATER
HEATING EQUIPMENT INCLUDING
ELECTRIC HEAT PUMP WATER HEATERS
IN ALL OF NORTH AMERICA. A. O.
SMITH SUPPORTS PRAGMATIC
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
POLICIES THE COMPANY RECENTLY
OUTLINED ITS VISIT ITS POSITION
IN AN EMPIRICAL WHITE PAPER
PUBLISHED IN SEPTEMBER WHICH I'M
HAPPY TO SHARE WITH THIS
COMMITTEE IF IT WOULD BE OF
INTEREST. CONSISTENT WITH THE
OPPOSITE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. A.
O. SMITH SUPPORTS ALL NEW
ELECTRIC RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION INCREASE FUNDING
FOR ELECTRIC HEAT PUMP WATER
HEATERS. THEY SUPPORTED SENATOR
BACKERS SB SIXTY EIGHT AND MOST
RECENTLY THERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED NINE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
OVER TWO YEARS FOR CRITICAL
INVENTS INVESTMENTS INEQUITABLE
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION.
TURNING TO THIS BILL SENATE
ARCHULETA DID A GREAT JOB
SUMMARIZING THE BILL SO I'D LIKE
TO JUST FOCUS ON TWO POINTS.
FIRST THE PERTINENT QUESTION FOR
THE COMMITTEE AS IT RELATES TO
THIS BILLS WHETHER THE STATE
OUGHT TO PLAY SOME ROLE. TO HELP
GUIDE THE LOCAL DECISION MAKING
PROCESS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
SEEKING TO REQUIRE RESIDENTIAL
AND COMMERCIAL OWNERS TO SWITCH
THEIR EXISTING APPLIANCES FROM
GAS TO ELECTRIC. AS A SENATOR
NOTICED NOTED THERE ARE UNIQUE
AND SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH DECARBONISING
EXISTING BUILDINGS AS OPPOSED TO
NEW BUILDINGS. SO SB THIRTY
NINETY THREE IS AN EFFORT TO
ENSURE THOSE CHALLENGES ARE
CONSIDERED. SECOND SB THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE IS THE FIRST PIECE
OF LEGISLATION SOLUTION PROPOSED
IN CALIFORNIA. PERTAINING TO
LOCAL ORDINANCES IN THE BUILT
ENVIRONMENT. THAT MEANS THERE IS
NOT MUCH TO WORK OFF OF BY WAY
OF PRESIDENT. WHICH IS WHY CAN
REGENERATE THE SENATOR'S
COMMENTS THAT THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS AND WE REMAIN COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION.
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE IN
TERMS OF WHAT ROLE THE STATION
ANYWAY. THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NOW TO- DO WHO DID YOU
SAY WAS REPLACING SCOTT WHICH-
CENTER ARCHULETA. I'M SORRY MR
JERRY DIDN'T I DIDN'T SOMEBODY
IS WALKING BY. WHO IS THE-
SPEAKER IN SUPPORT. YEAH IS
SPEAKING ON BEHALF THE COALITION
OF CALIFORNIA UTILITY PLEASE
YEAH WE HAD TO TWO SPEAKERS-
AREAS ON THE MIKE OKAY WELL-
PRESERVING YOURSELF YOU HAVE A
MINUTE AND A HALF- THANK YOU-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HUNTER STERN
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION OF.
OF CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES
BUT WE REPRESENT FOUR THOUSAND.
GAS WORKERS AT PG&E AND SDG AND
E. AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTEEN NINETY THREE- ST
ARCHULETA HAS OUTLINED ALL THE
MANY OF THE BENEFITS- WE SEE TWO
OTHER CRITICAL- INVALUABLE-
PIECES OF THIS LEGISLATION FIRST
AND FOREMOST IT'S AN EXTENSION.
OF WHAT THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION THE COMMISSION
ALREADY DOES- FOR NEW- FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION EXTENDING INTO THIS
EXISTING BUILT ENVIRONMENT-
WHICH IS ACTUALLY SOMETHING WE
SHOULD HAVE DONE PROBABLY A FEW
YEARS AGO SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL WE ALSO SUPPORTED FROM
THE STANDPOINT OF. A NATURAL AND
EFFECTIVE CONTRACTING OF THE GAS
SYSTEM LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
CITIES COUNTIES DON'T HAVE THE
KNOWLEDGE OR EXPERTISE TO DO
THIS IN A WAY WHICH IS SAFE.
RELIABLE FOR OUR MEMBERS
PROVIDING THE SERVICE TO THE
PUBLIC AND FOR THE CITIES AND
CAT AND FOR ALL THE PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY SO ON BEHALF OF.
MY MEMBERS THE WORKERS AND THE
PROVIDING OF THE SAFE RELIABLE
GAS SERVICE AND THE PLAN
DECARBONISATION OF EXISTING OF
THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT- WE
SUPPORT- S. B. THIRTEEN NINETY
THREE THANK YOU. OKAY WELL NOW
WE WILL MOVE TO SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT ANYONE HERE IN THE
GALLERY. WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF FOR THOSE- BECAUSE OF
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING LATE
APPEARANCE TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE CHAIRS- MAY
LIMIT TIME TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY WE'VE DONE THAT. BOB
ALL OTHERS THAT ARE NOT PART OF
A REORGANIZED PRESENTATION
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION.
ON THE MEASURE SO ANYONE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT LIMIT
COMMENTS THEIR NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON MEMBERS I DON'T
SEE ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY-
READY TO- TAKE THAT POSITION SO
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINES.
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE Q.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. OF ITEM
NUMBER ONE S. B. THIRTEEN NINETY
THREE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE SEVEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I DO HAVE A COUPLE IN Q.
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THE
FIRST COMMENT.
AT OUR FIRST COMMENT IS FROM
LINE FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE MOMENT FOR THE FIRST MY
NUMBER. NINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH WILL BRING HER
FROM THREE FIFTY SACRAMENTO AND
WE ARE OPPOSED TO TAKING POWER
FROM LOCAL. GOVERNMENT. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THINK HE'LL.
OKAY THERE'S NO AS SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE PIERRE DEL
FORCE YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES.
THE ON THE LINE JEFF. YEAH CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
. RIGHT HELLO MICHELLE HI
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M KIANA
PULLED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL. WE
ARE RESPECTFULLY IN A POSITION
TO HEAD THE THIRTEEN NINETY
THREE CURRENTLY WRITTEN. BECAUSE
WE HAVE JEOPARDIZING THE VERY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM BY MAKING HE
IS REVIEW UNNECESSARILY BROAD
AND RESTRICTIVE. AND BY CREATING
AN ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. TO MANAGE
INDIVIDUAL EXEMPTION. LOCAL
ENERGY CODES A ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST SUCCESSFUL
CLIMATE POLICIES THAT HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED BY MORE THAN FIFTY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OVER THE PAST YEAR.
THEY ALREADY REQUIRED TO BE COST
EFFECTIVE TO PROTECT LOCAL
CONSTITUENTS FROM LONG TERM
RISING GAS PRICES AND PROVIDE A
PATHWAY WILL DOWNSIZING THE
JACKET THEM THE COST EFFECTIVE
AND EQUITABLE MANNER. WE AGREE
WITH THE AUTHOR THAT THE STATE
HAS A ROLE TO PLAY. BUT WE NEED
THE STATE TO SUPPORT RATHER THAN
JUST THAT FOR THE PRESIDENT
RESTRICT THE TRANSITION FROM
FOSSIL ENERGY TO CLEAN THE
PORTABLE RENEWABLE HEAT AND HOT
WATER. WE HAVE HAD HELPFUL
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE OFFICE
OFFICE. I'M CONFIDENT AND OPEN
TO CONTINUING THE DISCUSSION.
BUT POINT AND BASED ON THE
COMMON LANGUAGE WITH ELBOWS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CAN WE GO
NOW TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO STATE THEIR
POSITION IN OPPOSITION ANYONE
HERE IN THE GALLERY. I DON'T SEE
ANYONE- THE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MODERATOR CAN YOU Q.
INDIVIDUALS IN OPPOSITION TO
ITEM ONE SB THIRTY NINETY THREE
. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO ASK BE THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE WE'VE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
ABOUT TEN IN Q. WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH. WE WERE GREETED PEOPLE
COMPELLING WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
SPEAKER. THANK YOU I'M FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. DAN
CHANDLER RIPLEY FIFTY HUMBOLDT
WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
SPEAKER. THANK YOU I'M TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHERYL TO
KNEEL AND CHAMPAGNE IN THE
VALLEY CHAPTER OF CLIMATE
REALITY IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
NEXT SPEAKER. THANK YOU I'M
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS DIANA WINE AND ON
CHAIR THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
CLIMATE REALITY CHAPTER AND-
CALLING IN IN STRONG OPPOSITION
AB THIRTEEN NINETY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER.
THANK YOU LINE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DEBBIE MY
TELEPHONE REPRESENT PENINSULA
INTERFAITH CLIMATE ACTION AND
I'M ALSO WITH THE FOSSIL THREE
BUILDINGS OF SILICON VALLEY NO
WE BOTH OF THE GROUP'S STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT BIGGER. THANK YOU I'M FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FIVE
FOUR. THANK YOU MAKE SNYDER ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN NINETY
THREE. THAT WAS A SPEAKER IN
SUPPORT WILL MAKE THAT NOTE
WE'RE NOW ASKING FOR SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. OF MODERATOR PLEASE
CALL THE NEXT BIGGER. THANK YOU
LINE TIME PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ROSE AND
WE'RE CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
KANETO CLIMATE COALITION IN
VENTURA COUNTY AND WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AT THE ONE
THREE NINE THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ROBERT WHITE HAIR AND
REPRESENTS AMATIL CLIMATE ACTION
TEAM MEMBER OF DOLLARS ACTION
NETWORK OF CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY. SO OPPOSE SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LIFELINE THREE
EIGHT. I DON'T THIRTY HELLO MY
NAME IS FELIX BOOGA I AM A
RESIDENT OF MILPITAS HI I'M
CALLING FROM A POSITION TO BE
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE OKAY.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER. THANK
YOU I'M FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BY NAME IS JOHN SCHAEFER I'M A
MEMBER OF THREE FIFTY DOT ORG
AND AS YOU HEARD WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANKS. THANK YOU ARE THE
MORE SPEAKERS. WE HAVE ABOUT
THREE MORE OF BY THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
BRUCE NAGLE I'M PART OF A
SUSTAINABLE SILICON VALLEY IN
CARPENTRY SILICON VALLEY WHO
STRONGLY OPPOSE- THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER. THANK
YOU Y. FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HELLO MY NAME IS BRUCE TODD
JOHN REPRESENTING CARBON PRETTY
POLANCO AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
S. B. NINE THREE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. THANK YOU
WE HAVE TO ASK WHY FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
RHONDA FRANK RICHARD WHEN HE
AMHERST ST UNIT FOR ITS LENGTH
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE MINISTRY
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THEM.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT GROUP OR NEXT
BIGGER. THANK YOU I'M FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
DAN HARKEY I LIVE IN OAKLAND AND
I'M WITH CLIMATE HEALTH NOW AND
ALSO THREE FIFTY BAY. STRONGLY
OPPOSE. VERY WELL NEXT BIGGER.
THANK YOU LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON OF THE
MACHINE CARE I AND NUMER TWO
SAID HE ONLY GOT THE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS- IN GREAT SUPPORT IT
WAS IN THE WRONG YOU THINK YOU.
OKAY THAT IS A COLOR IN SUPPORT
WILL MAKE THE NOTE BUT WE'RE ON
COLORS IN OPPOSITION OF YOUR
COLOR IN OPPOSITION. MODERATOR
PLEASE Q. ANY. OTHER CALLERS
THERE ANY. THANK YOU I HAVE NO%
FURTHER LINE THANK YOU OKAY
THANKS VERY MUCH WILL COME NOW
TO. THE COMMITTEE IF THERE ARE
ANY MEMBERS OF WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE ANY COMMENTS OR MOTIONS-
SENATOR BAKER. CAN WE HAVE IS
MIKE ACTIVATED. OKAY THANKS A
PRETERISM JUST REMEMBER CITIES
HAVE ENACTED REACH CODES TO
REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS FROM
BUILDINGS AND CLIMATE PLANS TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS FOR COMMUNITIES
MORE BROADLY SO MANY WAYS OUR
CITIES HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN
LABORATORIES AND I THINK VERY
IMPORTANT LABORATORIES TO SEE
TRY POLICIES AND SEE WHAT'S
WORKING AND NOW SOME CITIES ARE
CONSIDERING TAKING THE NEXT STEP
AND STARTED THE LONG DIFFICULT
PATH OF REDUCING EMISSIONS FROM
EXISTING BUILDINGS AND WE KNOW
IT'S URGENTLY NEEDED THE AB
THREE THIRTY TWO THIRTY TWO
REPORT SHOWED HOW DIFFICULT WILL
BE TO HIT OUR EMISSIONS
REDUCTION TARGETS FROM
BUILDINGS. EVEN AN INCREDIBLY
AGGRESSIVE REPLACE ON BURNOUT
ORDINANCE WOULD NOT BE ENOUGH TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS 40% BY TWENTY
THIRTY AS OUR GOALS- BUT RATHER
THAN- THE YOU KNOW THE KIND OF
AB EMBRACE THIS EXPERIMENTAL
APPROACH WITH THIS BILL WOULD DO
WOULD CREATE A LITIGATION
NIGHTMARE AND EFFECTIVE PREVENT
ANY NEW BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
MEASURES OF THE LOCAL LEVEL. THE
BILL GIVES VAST NEW APPROVAL
AUTHORITIES TO THE CC OVER ANY
KIND OF LOCAL ROLE EVEN THAT
LOCALLY PASSED BALLOT MEASURES.
AND PREVENTS THE CDC FROM
APPROVING ANY LOCAL REQUIREMENT
THAT CROSSES ANY OF A LIST
VAGUELY DEFINED OUTLINES SO I
DO. A YOU KNOW ONE STRONGLY
RAISE MY CONCERNS I DO WANT TO.
SAY I THINK THE AUTHOR RAISES
SOME VALID ISSUES WITH THE BILL
I THINK IN THEIR ENTHUSIASM FOR
TAKING ACTION ON CLIMATE SOME
CITIES. MAIN ACT ORTON SAYS THAT
OVER REACH. AND THEY MAY NOT
REALIZE THAT EXEMPTIONS FOR
CERTAIN CATEGORIES OF BUILDINGS
ARE CERTAIN USE CASES ARE
JUSTIFIED AT LEAST TEMPORARILY.
BECAUSE RECENTLY COST EFFECTIVE
LECTURES OPTIONS ARE NOT YET
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE. SO I CAN
IMAGINE IN A WORKING THE FUTURE
WITH THE AUTHOR ON A BILL THAT
REQUIRES A CC TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE. TO CITIES CONSIDERING
DECARBONISATION ORTON SAYS AND
HELPS THEM UNDERSTAND WHERE LACK
OF AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGY WOULD
MAKE SOLUTIONS. I'M IN FEASIBLE
ARE VERY EXPENSIVE ON BUT THIS
IS NOT THAT BILL AND AS IT
COMMUNICATED TO THE AUTHOR I'M
GOINGTO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL
AND I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO JOIN ME. IN
PREVENTING WHAT'S REALLY AN
ATTACK ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE CLIMATE
CRISIS. OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER SPEAKERS CENTER BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AS INDIVIDUAL WHO. WORK
NOT ONLY FOR UTILITY OF AN
ENVIRONMENTAL NONPROFIT THIS IS
A COMMON SENSE APPROACH WE'VE
SEEN THE- GREAT INTENTIONS. AND
INTENT BY INDIVIDUALS BOTH
LOCALLY. AND STATE AND FEDERAL
TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS ABOUT
CLIMATE AND THEY'RE LEGIT. BUT
MANY TIMES WE SET ARBITRARY
LAUDABLE GOALS THAT ARE
ASPIRATIONAL AT BEST IN HARD TO
REACH. THE REASON WHY WE SAW SO
MANY PEOPLE LOSE THEIR LIFE LIVE
HERE IN TEXAS DURING THAT WINTER
VORTEX. WAS TO THE FACT THOSE
WERE ALL ELECTRIFIED HOMES.
THOSE HOMES STILL BEEN PLUMBED
FOR GAS WITH GAS BILLS
INDIVIDUALS WOULD BE ALIVE
TODAY. I THINK IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THE ROLE THAT GAS CONTINUES TO
PLAY WE WOULD NOT HAVE MET OUR
CLIMATE COLD. GOALS AS A NATION.
ARE PARIS ACCORD GOALS IF IT
WASN'T FOR NATURAL GAS LAST YEAR
SO I JUST WANTED TO BE- YOU HAS
WHAT THEY SAY. POMPOM FELICIAN A
PRETTY WISE OR WHATEVER THE.
TERM IS AND I UNDERSTAND THAT.
THE STILL ROLLED. THE IMPACT ON-
OUR OUR ENVIRONMENT WE ALL YOU
KNOW ARE COMMITTED TO THAT
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION IF
NOT THE WORLD AND MUCH OF WHAT
WE DO BUT TO CONTINUE TO ASSIST.
YOU KNOW PUT THESE ASPIRATIONAL
GOALS AND RESTRICT. COMMONSENSE
APPROACHES TO WHAT A LOT OF POOR
FOLKS NEED IN THEIR HOMES TO IN
ORDER TO HEAT THEIR HOMES I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MATTER
THANK YOU GO TO CENTER GONZALEZ
AND SENATOR EGGMAN- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- HAVE A
QUESTION FOR- THE SENATOR. IF I
MAY THROUGH THE CHESS ABSOLUTELY
YES HI THANK YOU- WHY I THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS ISSUE UP
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE GOT- LOTS OF
IDEAS AND THOUGHTS ON ON MANY
SITES BUT- THE ARGUMENTS IN
OPPOSITION JUST. OF COURSE STATE
THE YOU KNOW. THE IMPACTS OF
DOING SORT OF A STATE WIDE
APPROACH VERSUS GOING THROUGH
LOCAL ORDINANCES. I MEAN HOW DO
YOU ENVISION THE- THE CAUTIOUS
FOR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THAT IS A THAT IS A REAL
ISSUE HERE. AND I DON'T SEE
WHERE ARE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES CAN. YOU KNOW REALLY
BE A TARGETED- WITH THIS WITH
THE APPROACH- STATED IN YOUR
BILL SO CAN YOU JUST ADDRESS
THAT I KNOW IT'S A BIG QUESTION
BUT I JUST WOULD LIKE TO GET
YOUR- OKAY. THANK YOU SENATOR I
JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT A COUPLE
THINGS IN A MINUTE ASCA- ANTHONY
SAMPSON TO JUMP IN AS WELL. THE
ISSUE HERE IS ITS MUNICIPALITIES
CITY GOVERNMENTS THEY CHANGE ALL
THE TIME. EVERY NOVEMBER EVERY
FOUR YEARS WHATEVER THAT IS AND
- I KNOW WE'RE ALL TRYING TO
WORK ON OUR ENVIRONMENT I TOO AM
DOING THE SAME THING. I AM JUST
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FAMILY WHO
CAN'T AFFORD FOR SOMEONE TO
KNOCK ON THE DOOR AND SAID
YOU'VE GOT TO CHANGE YOUR GAS
STOVE AND YOUR WAY OF EATING-
INTO ELECTRIC. SYSTEM AND THEY
CAN'T AFFORD IT. WILL YOU BE
HEARD WHAT WAS SAID TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED TO FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND FOR. THIS BILL ALL IT DOES
IS IF ASSUMING FOUR SQUARE
BLOCKS IN YOUR DISTRICT ARE
GOING TO BE AFFECTED WELL ALL IT
MEANS IS THAT THE CITY COUNCIL
WOULD HAVE TO GO TO THE STATE-
A. N. TALK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION. AND THEY IN
TURN WOULD OVERSEE WHAT THEY'RE
DOING AND IF IT'S FOR. THEY'LL
BACK IT IF IT'S NOT. THEN THEY
WON'T THAT'S ALL IT IS JUST A OF
THE BALANCING THE CHECKS AND
BALANCES SO COMMUNITIES ARE
ARBITRARILY TOLD TO DO
SOMETHING. WITHOUT THE STATE
ACTUALLY DOING SOMETHING SO IT'S
JUST THE COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
THE CITY AND THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION BEFORE ACTION
IS TAKEN. THAT'S IT AND REMEMBER
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OLDER
STRUCTURES NOT NEW ONES IF
THERE'S GONNA BE A BRAND YOU A
TOWN HOUSE BUILT OR BRAND NEW
HOMES BUILT GRANTED. THEN
BECAUSE IT'S BRAND NEW THEN THE
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES WILL
PROBABLY SAY WE'D LIKE TO HAVE
THOSE- WITH ELECTRIC STOVES AND
SOMEONE. BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MOM AND POP AND COMMUNITIES THAT
WOULD LIKE WOULD NEED A CHOICE
SO ANTHONY SAMPSON IF YOU'D LIKE
TO JUMP IN. I WOULD APPRECIATE
IT NOT THAT THAT YOU CAN ANSWER
SUFFICIENT DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- CENTER
GONZALEZ NO I DON'T AT THIS
POINT IT'S GOING TO BE HARD FOR
ME TO SUPPORT THIS IS WELL JUST
GIVEN THAT THE CURRENT- LANGUAGE
BUT I WILL CONTINUE TO. WORK
WITH THAT THAT THE SENATOR TO
SEE IF THERE'S- AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO AND THAT'S ALL I CAN
ASK THE COMMITTEE TO CONTINUE
WITH ME SO WE CAN LOOK AT
AMENDMENTS TO THE FUTURE AND
MOVE THE BILL ALONG. AND I'LL
CERTAINLY WORK WITH THANK YOU
SHARE AND EVERYONE ELSE. LET ME-
GO TO CENTER EGGMAN NOW. THANK
YOU MUCH MISS CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
I. ALSO A SOMEBODY AND I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUE WHO POINTED OUT THAT.
HE UED TO WORK FOR UTILITY.
AGENCY TALKING ABOUT THIS BILL
BUT LIKE MANY OF US I SERVED ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. AND I THINK
EVEN MORE SO THAN THE STATE CITY
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DON'T MOVE
FASTER THAN THE PEOPLE THAT THEY
REPRESENT BECAUSE WITH. THE
CLOSEST TO IT. AND I CERTAINLY
STARTED MY INTEREST IN WORKING
IN- ENERGY AND ANNA AND WASTE
TALK ABOUT THAT EARLIER TODAY
DURING MY TIME. AS A LOCAL A
LOCAL PERSON AND REALLY
LISTENING TO WHAT PEOPLE WERE
INTERESTED IN ANNA AND
INTERESTING THINGS THAT YOU CAN
OFTENTIMES SEE. MORE AT A LOCAL
LEVEL BEFORE YOU MOVED TO A
STATEWIDE LEVEL- SO I WILL ALSO
HAVE A LOT. OF HER TIME
SUPPORTING THE SAME PEOPLE HEARD
ABOUT MY FONDNESS FOR MY-
HUNDRED YEAR OLD HOUSE IN MY GAS
STOVE AND THE ACT THAT I OWNED
THAT- AND I ALSO. IN A CITY THAT
. NOTHING I'VE SEEN IN ORDER TO
GET OUT AHEAD BECAUSE AGAIN-
THERE ARE DIRECTLY TIED TO A WHO
ELECTS THEM- SO I DON'T I
WOULDN'T WANNA STICK TO SLOW
DOWN THE PROGRESS THAT IS GOING
TO BE VERY DIFFICULT WE ALL KNOW
TO MAKE TO GET TO THIS POINT
THAT WE ALL WANT TO GET TO. ON
SO I WILL ALSO NOT BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NIGHT ARE YOU
KNOW I HEARD I HEARD SOME
COMMENTS ABOUT HOW THIS BILL
NEEDS WORK AND HOW. MEMBERS ARE
WILLING TO ADDRESS KIND OF THE
GOALS OF THE BILL. WE CAN'T AND
IT'S EARLY IN THE PROCESS
MEMBERS- JUST A STRAIGHT OUT NO
VOTE ON ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES
BILLS AT ADDRESSING A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE I THINK IS- IS A
SMALL THING TO ASK JUST TO ALLOW
HIM TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE
BILL. FROM MY FROM MY STANDPOINT
OUTLOOK OUR STATE IS NOT ONLY
WORKING ON. A RENEWABLE SOURCES
OF ENERGY WERE ALSO TRYING TO
TRANSFORM OUR- OUR GAS GRID. TO
INJECT RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS
THAT IS EASIER ON THE
ENVIRONMENT. THAT HELPS US
ADDRESS OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
GOALS AND OTHER ECONOMIC GOALS.
AND SO- I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT CERTAIN AREAS THAT
HAVE DON'T HAVE ACCESS. TO-
CERTAIN LEVELS OF BALANCING OF
THE GRID- IMAGINE COMPLETELY- IN
SOME CASES- POSING SOME-
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE- VERY
BURDENSOME FEDERAL COULD REALLY
HELP BUILD OPPOSITION TO A LOT
OF OUR STATE'S GOALS IN IN
TRANSITIONING TO CLEANER POWER
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO-
EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE THAT HAS A
LEGISLATURE WE HAVE TO LISTEN TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT ARE ARE
REALLY SUFFERING RIGHT NOW AND
HAVING TO PAY THOSE BILLS. RIGHT
NOW CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY I KNOW
SAN DIEGO RECENTLY- THAT GOT A
LOT OF FLAK FOR HAVING THE
HIGHEST RATES NOT ONLY IN
CALIFORNIA BUT IN THE COUNTRY
AND IT'S HARD FOR US TO SELL-
RENEWABLE AGENDA WHEN WE HAVE
THE HIGHEST RATES AND THEN WE
HAVE TO IMPOSE OTHER
REQUIREMENTS. ON COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY- THE WORKING POOR WHO
ARE HAVING A HARD TIME
STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW I THINK
THAT THIS BILL DESERVES. AT
LEAST SOME SOME CONSIDERATIONS
SOME ADDITIONAL WORK IF I. YOU
CAN IMAGINE A OF FACES A HEAVY
LIFT TRYING TO. ACCOMPLISH VERY
HOT DIFFICULT THING I WISH THE
AUTHOR LOTS OF LUCK IN DOING
THAT AND I HOPE WE CAN. ALLOW
HIM TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
ISSUE SO WILLING TO DO SO AS HE
HAS EXPRESSED SO AS FOR AN AYE
VOTE FOR THIS BILL- AND IF WE
CAN NOW- DID YOU HAVE ANY- SIR
DOLLY. MOVE THE BILL- DID YOU
WANT TO MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS AND- THANK YOU MISTER
NAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR AYE
VOTE I THANK YOU FOR THE ABILITY
TO ALLOW ME. TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU IN THE COMMITTEE TO. GO
FORWARD WITH AMENDMENTS TONIGHT-
ASK FOR A VOTE TO MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD. THANK YOU OKAY- BUT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE. WESSEL II. WESSEL HI
DOLLY. DOLLY HI BAKER. BAKER NO
FOR JUST. PORGES I BRADFORD
BRADFORD HI DOT. EGGMAN.
GONZALEZ GROWTH. HELLO I
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE
. MAN. RUBIO RUBIO AYE STERN.
STERN NO- SEVEN AS INTERNALS
OKAY US SEVEN AS TO KNOWS- DID
WE HAVE ABSENT MEMBERS ON THAT
YES OKAY SO WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS OKAY I
WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO
S. NINETY EIGHT CHAIR HE WON. BY
A SENATOR MEN BUT THERE RELATING
TO LOAD SERVING ENTITIES. IN
THIS BILL WE HAVE- ONE LEAD
SUPPORT ORGANIZED PRESENTATION
ONE SPEAKER IN SUPPORT INTO IN
OPPOSITION SO WE'LL DO. THREE
MINUTES FOR THE SPEAKER IN
SUPPORT WILL SPLIT THOSE THREE
MINUTES BY THE TWO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. SENATOR MAN. THANK
YOU CHAIRED BY SO THANK YOU TO
COMMITTEE STAFF OF BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY AS THIS ON THIS BILL I'M
PRESENTING SP EIGHTY ONE WHICH
CLARIFIES THE PUBLIC UTILITY
COMMISSIONS THORLEY TO ENFORCE
LOAD SERVING ENTITIES ARE L. AS
HE'S- AND THEIR COMPLIANCE WITH
THE PROCESS KNOWN AS INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLANNING OR I. R. PEAS
ARE CURRENTLY AT LAW REQUIRES L.
S. EAST TO DEVELOP PLANS TO MEET
THE RENEWABLE ENERGY GOALS AND
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS TARGETS
WHILE ALSO MINIMIZING COSTS. AND
ENSURING GREATER LIABILITY THIS
PLAN KNOWN AS THE I. R. P. IS A
KEY FACTOR IN DETERMINING THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO REACH ITS
CLIMATE GOALS SB THREE FIFTY
AUTHORED BY THEN PRESIDENT PRO
TEMPORE A DATE KEVIN DE LEÓN-
CREATED INITIAL MANDATE
PRIORITIES THIS BILL REQUIRES
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATORS AND
OTHER ELECTRIC PROVIDERS TO
DEVELOP I OUR FEES AND SUBMIT
THEM TO THE P. YOU SEE. FOR
APPROVAL EVERY TWO YEARS.
RECENTLY THE P. YOU SEE
COMPLETED THE SECOND TWO YEAR
CYCLE OF THE I. R. P. AND IS
CURRENTLY PLANNING FOR AN
ADDITIONAL CYCLE WHICH WILL
FOCUS ENTIRELY- OUR FOCUS
CLOSELY ON EXISTING NATURAL GAS
POWER PRICES. AND PLANNING FOR A
100% CLEAN ENERGY BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. THE BILL BEFORE US
TODAY WOULD REQUIRE THE P. YOU
SEE IS PART OF THE I. R. P.
REQUIRE EACH LOAD SERVING
ENTITY. UNDERTAKES EFFICIENT
PROCUREMENT TO REACH ELECTRICITY
SECTOR GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS. HOW DOES THIS WORK
IF YOU SEE CURRENTLY ALREADY HAS
REGULATORY AUTHORITY OVER LSTS
AND IS IN REQUIRED BY LAW TO
OVERSEE THE PROCESS. OF LSE
SUBMITTING THEIR PLANS. THE PC
IS ALSO REQUIRED TO SCHEDULE
PERIODIC UPDATES TO THOSE PLANS
REVIEW THEM AND ULTIMATELY
ENSURE THAT LSE'S MEET THEIR
OBJECTIVES. IN AN EFFORT TO
PROVIDE THE IF YOU SEE WITH ALL
THE TOOLS IT NEEDS TO ENSURE
THAT THESE LSTS MEET THEIR
GOALS. SB EIGHTY ONE REQUIRED IF
YOU SEE THE INSURER SUFFICIENT
PROCUREMENT EFFORTS ARE BEING
MADE. AND CREATE A PLAN BY
AUTHORIZING P. U. C. ASSESSED
PENALTIES IF AN LSE FAILS TO
MEET ITS OBLIGATIONS. THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO ALLOW THE PUCO
AUTHORIZE ADDITIONAL PROCUREMENT
WHEN NEEDED. HI THIS IS NOT ONLY
A NATURAL NEXT STEP FOR THE
EVOLUTION I THE I. R. P. IT'S A
NECESSARY NEXT STEP. THE I. R.
P. WAS DESIGNED PRIMARILY AS A
PLANNING PROCESS BUT IT KEEPS
IDENTIFYING SHORTFALLS. IN
NOVEMBER TWENTIETH NINETEEN THE
PC HAD TO ORDER PROCUREMENT OVER
THREE THOUSAND MEGAWATTS FOR
NEAR TERM LIKE RELIABILITY. LAST
SUMMER THE QC ORDERED
PROCUREMENT OF OVER ELEVEN
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS FOR NEAR AND
MEDIUM RELIABILITY. ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS IF YOU SEE HAS LOOKED
AT THE SYSTEMS ANALYSIS AND
IDENTIFIED SUBSTANTIAL
SHORTFALLS. SHOWING THE NEED FOR
THE P. YOU SEE TO BE ABLE TO ACT
WHEN THEY IDENTIFY THE
SHORTFALLS. AS SUCH THIS BILL
PRINT WOULD PROMOTE COMPLIANCE
WITH THE PUC'S ORDERS. AND
ESTABLISH A FRAMEWORK FOR THEM-
TO ENFORCE AGAINST IF THEY FAIL
TO COMPLY. SB EIGHT EIGHTY ONE
IS SPONSORED BY THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND
SUPPORTED BY LABOR LABOR
COALITIONS SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
ELECTRIC WORKERS. THE COALITION
OF CALIFORNIA UTILITY PAYING-
EMPLOYEES. AS AS IN BY ORDER.
SUCH AS THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND ENVIRO VOTERS AND
IT IS HERE CLUB. JOINING US
TODAY TO TESTIFY I HAVE MORE
EXPECT AND WESTERN STATES ENERGY
MANAGER AND SENIOR ANALYST AT
THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS. OKAY WE WILL-
DAUGHTER MARC. SPECTOR- YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES SIR. GREAT THANK
YOU CAN HEAR ME OKAY YES.
EXCELLENT THANKS AND GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON
MARCH FACT WITH THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND I'M
SPEAKING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHTY EIGHTY ONE. OVERALL THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE TOOLS AND
PROCESSES IN PLACE. TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRICITY
SECTOR ACHIEVED FIFTY
CARBONIZATION AND CLEAN ENERGY
GOAL. NOW BACK IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED SB THREE
FIFTY WHICH ESTABLISHED THE
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING OR
IRP PROCESS. AND IT REQUIRED
BOTH LIVING ENTITY DETERMINE HOW
TO MEET FUTURE ELECTRICITY
DEMAND WHILE ENSURING GREATER
RELIABILITY MAINTAINING
AFFORDABILITY ACHIEVING
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND CLEAN
ENERGY GOAL. THE R. P. HAS SINCE
DEVELOPED INTO A ROBUST PLANNING
PROCESS BUT THERE ARE STILL NO
REQUIREMENT IN PLACE- THAT MODE
SERVING ENTITIES MEET THE
FABULOUS GOAL REDUCING GLOBAL
WARMING POLLUTION. AND PROCURING
THE NECESSARY CLEAN ENERGY TO
ACHIEVE THE COMMISSION
PRODUCTION. THERE ARE COMPLIANCE
REQUIREMENTS IN PLACE AS PART OF
THE RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD
THAT DO ENSURE BOTH SERVING
ENTITIES REACH 60% RENEWABLE
ENERGY BY TWENTY THIRTY. BUT
IT'S CLEAR FROM THE R. P. THAT
MOTORING ANY WILL NEED TO GO
ABOVE AND BEYOND TO MEET THE
ELECTRICITY SECTOR'S GLOBAL
WARMING EMISSIONS REDUCTION
TARGET. SO THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE GREATER CLARITY THAT THE
G. P. S. B. SHALL REQUIRE
MOTORING ENTITIES TO ACHIEVE
THEIR GOAL AND I LEFT HE FAILED
TO MEET THEIR OBLIGATIONS THE
BILL. CLARIFY YOU'D BE READY TO
ASSESS PENALTIES IN ORDER.
BACKSTOPS PROCUREMENT IF
NECESSARY. IN SUMMARY HE TO
ENSURE CALIFORNIA GDP
CARBONIZATION AND CLEAN ENERGY
GOALS WE NEED THIS NARROW YET
NECESSARY STATUTORY
CLARIFICATION. THANK YOU AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU WILL GO TO SPEAKERS
HERE IN THE GALLERY IN SUPPORT
OF ITEM TWO S. B. EIGHTY EIGHT
ONE. WE HAVE ANY SPEAKERS THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN I'M JOHN WHITE
WITH THE CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN
AND- WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL WE THINK IT WILL STRENGTHEN
OVERSIGHT AND PERFORMANCE BY THE
UTILITIES AND THE OTHER LITTLE
SERVING ENTITIES RESPIRABLE OKAY
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN THE
GALLERY. OKAY WE'LL GO TO THE
MODERATOR ASKED FOR SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM TWO S. B. EIGHT
EIGHT ONE. AND TWO PLEASE LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES MODERATOR PLEASE CALL
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT EIGHT ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE. ZERO AT THE TIME. I
HAVE ABOUT THREE LINES IN Q.
ABOUT TO LINE THIRTY SEVEN
PEOPLE HAVE. SANTIAGO WAS
CALIFORNIAN FINANCIAL LITERACY
CALLING IN SUPPORT AND WE DON'T
FEEL LIKE DIMINISH THEIR SUPPORT
FOR SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA. VERY
WELL NINETY ONE TWENTY NINE.
TWENTY NINE PEOPLE HAVE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBER IS THE
KEY TO KARATE WITH NRDC ALSO
CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MAKE YOU MINE TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE
HAVE. CAN YOU BE CARRIED ON
BEHALF OF TURN THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK WITH THE SUPPORT
OF AMENDED PETITION. THANK YOU
I'M THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YOU CAN HEAR ME YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS BRUCE
NAGLE SUSTAINABLE SO COMPELLING
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER
. THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU. OKAY VERY
WELL NOW WILL GO TO THE SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION THE ORGANIZED
PRESENTATION HAS TWO SPEAKERS AT
A REGISTER TO ANDREW. KAKASHI
DAR WITH US HELLO CALIFORNIA
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON AND-
THEN JEFF CIPHERS WITH CINEMA
KEEPING POWER- EACH WILL GET A
MINUTE AND A HALF OF. MISTER
NKOSI DAR. UP ARE YOU THERE.
JEREMY HERE IN THE GALLERY. WELL
YOU'RE IN THE GALLERY OKAY- GOOD
AFTERNOON SHERRY MEMBERS MY NAME
IS INJURED BECAUSE IT ARE FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON FIRST
WE WANT TO THANK ALL THE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US GENEROUSLY
GIVING US- THEIR LIMITED TIME
STUFF WORK ON THIS BILL HAS BEEN
EXEMPLARY AND THINK THAT
RESPECTFUL THANK YOU WE ALSO
GREATLY APPRECIATED CENTER
TAKING THE TIME TO HEAR OUR
CONCERNS THANK YOU SENATOR. SB
EIGHTY ONE INCREASES THE
PENALTIES FOR THOSE SERVING
ENTITIES THAT DO NOT MEET
RENEWABLE PROCUREMENT STANDARDS
TO BE CLEAR S. C. FULLY SUPPORTS
CALIFORNIA'S GOALS AND LAWS OF
CARBON NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE IN FACT IS PART OF
OUR CORPORATE GOALS
UNFORTUNATELY SB EIGHT EIGHT ONE
DOES NOT COMPORT WITH CURRENT
LAW AND PRECEDENT AS ESTABLISHED
BY SB THREE FIFTY CURRENT
STATUTE PROVIDES THAT IF A
RETAIL SELLER DEMONSTRATES THAT
IS TAKEN ALL REASONABLE ACTIONS
UNDER ITS CONTROL. THEN THE CPUC
CAN CHOOSE TO WAIVE PENALTIES
UNFORTUNATELY SB EIGHTY ONE
REMOVES THE DISCRETION OF THE
CPC AND US UNFAIRLY PUNISHES LOW
SERVING ENTITIES FOR UNFORESEEN
EVENTS AND ACTIONS BEYOND OUR
CONTROL. ANY NUMBER OF POTENTIAL
ISSUES OUTSIDE OF OUR CONTROL
CAN CAUSE DELAY LOCAL PERMITTING
DELAYS SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES A
PANDEMIC THEREFORE S. C.
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS AND
AMENDMENTS SB EIGHT EIGHT ONE
THAT WOULD GRANT THE CPUC
DISCRETION. IN CLOSING S. C.
OPPOSE S. B. SUBMITTED I
RESPECTFULLY URGES YOU KNOW VOTE
pTHANK YOU PERFECT TIMING THANK
YOU AND NOW WILL GO TO- JEFF
SINCE I FIRST. HE PERSON OR ON
THE- VERY GOOD. PLEASE BEGIN I'M
ONLINE YET. I'M JUST DRIVERS
WITH THE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR HOUR
IF YOU SEE A CERTAIN PHENOMENA
MENDOCINO COUNTY AND ALSO
SPEAKING ON THE APPLE CAL PTSD
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY
THREE CPA AND REGRETTABLY WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
EIGHTY ONE COMMAND SO WE DO
AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR IT IS
ESSENTIAL TO ENSURE STEADY
PROGRESS ON CUTTING EMISSIONS.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THE MECHANISM
SHOULD BE CLEAR AND AVOID
CREATING UNNECESSARY REPAIR
COSTS. AND IS CURRENTLY DRAFT
THE BILL. CREEK GAS REDUCTIONS
TO INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANS TO
MAP IN ACTION IT WOULD LIMIT THE
ABILITY OF POWER PROVIDERS THE
COST EFFECTIVELY MEET THE
STATE'S CHRONICLES. INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLANS ON GASES ABOUT
FUTURE CONDITONS AND ARE OUT OF
DATE IT'S GOING TO BE A
PUBLISHED. AND FORCING POWER
PROVIDERS TO STRICTLY FOLLOW
THEM WOULD PREVENT US FROM
MAKING USE OF NEW TECHNOLOGY AND
FROM PREVENTING. PROTECTING
RATEPAYERS FROM UNPLEASANT
MARKET SURPRISE. L. 8% OF THE
AND- WITH TO SUGGEST. FIRST
PUBLISHED CLEARLY DEFINED
INTERIM RENEWABLE CARBON FREE
ENERGY TARGETS IN THE RPF. FROM
YEAR TWENTY THIRTY THREE TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. SO THE CLIMATE
PROGRESS CAN BE ENFORCED. AND
SECOND TO ALLOW THE PEOPLE YOU
SEE TO APPLY MEANINGFUL
FINANCIAL PENALTIES FOR ALL
KINDS OF OUR PROVIDERS THE
FAILED TO COMPLY. CONFIDENT WITH
SOME CHANGES WE CAN PUBLIC MEDIA
WAY THAT WORKS UNFORTUNATELY THE
BILL DOESN'T WORK TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND I WILL GO TO-
SPEAKERS. IN OPPOSITION
BEGINNING WITH THE GALLERY OF
THIRTY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU ARE MELISSA CORTEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION I'M THE WRONG
LINE ON MY APOLOGIES WE ARE
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
OKAY WERE IN OPPOSITION. YES
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS LORD AS
HE MENACE THE SAN DIEGO GAS AND
ELECTRIC WE ARE OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED. Q. THANK YOU- NECKS-
ANYWAY OTHER SPEAKERS HERE IN
THE GALLERY. WE'LL GO TO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF ITEM
TWO IS P. EIGHT EIGHT ONE- WE'LL
JUST CALLERS ON THE LINE
MODERATE PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF THINK A LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION A POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO ASK B.
EIGHT EIGHT ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO AT THIS TIME. OVER
TWENTY SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HELLO EMILY PAPPAS WOULD MEAN
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE SOVIET FROM
US RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE ON BEHALF
OF AND FEET THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE- NEXT THANK YOU I
HAVE ABOUT THREE MORE IN LINE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALICIA PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF
DANIEL DAY CLEAN ENERGY AND ALSO
CALIFORNIA CHOICE ENERGY
AUTHORITY AND WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED ON SB EIGHT EIGHT
ONE THANK YOU. NEXT SPEAKER.
THANK YOU I'M FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CHASE AND I COULD ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION ALSO
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY MR CIPHERS.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER. THANK
YOU I'M THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS HILLARY
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF CENTRAL COAST
COMMUNITY ENERGY OKAY SHORT I.
CRICKETER SERVING THIRTY THREE
COMMUNITIES IN SANTA CRUZ
MODERATE BENITO AND A BARBARA
AND FAMILIES OBISPO COUNTY. AND
WE ARE ALSO OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED- TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
OF. THE COUNTY SAN MR SPICER.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU OKAY WILL COME TO THE
COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE ANYONE OF
COMMITTEE LIKE TO MAKE ANY
COMMENTS. SENATE RUBIO SEVEN
HAND OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- PRESS WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE
RAYNOLDS ADDED TEN PART IN THAT-
IT'S CLARIFIED WHO HAS C.
ACCOUNTABILITY FACTOR HERE BUT I
KNOW THAT I PERSONALLY GOT A LOT
OF OPPOSITION AT THE LAST MINUTE
AND I ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT DT
THE AUTHOR IS STILL WORKING OUT
SOME OF THE DETAILS AND SO I
JUST WANNA. EXPRESS SOME OF MY
CONCERNS BUT I WANT TO GIVE THE
AUTHOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
ON THIS BILL AND CIRCLE BACK
WITH MY OFFICE CELL RIGHT NOW I
WILL- SUPPORTED BUT AGAIN I WANT
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT I KNOW
THAT THERE IS TALKS ABOUT
POSSIBLE LANGUAGE OUR THAT WOULD
MAKE IT BETTER IN AVOID
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES IN THE
FUTURE AND IT YOU KNOW I COULD
FALL INTO BUT AT THIS POINT I
WANT TO BE ABLE TO BE SUPPORTIVE
BUT I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR THANK YOU. BAKER
THANK YOU OKAY. SO I'M A CO
OFFICE BUILDING IN A SUPPORTED
TODAY BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT- WE
BECAUSE THE R. P. WHICH IS THE
MAIN WAY THAT THE PC'S GONNA BE
MANAGING ELECTRICITY SECTOR
TOWARDS A 100% CLEAN ENERGY OVER
THE NEXT TWENTY FIVE YEARS WE
NEED TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THE
R. P. PROCESS IS MORE THAN JUST
A PLANNING PROCESS THAT EVERYONE
HAS AN OBLIGATION TO FOLLOW
THROUGH ON THESE PLANS. AND HIT
THE RELIABILITY CLEAN ENERGY
TARGETS HAD BEEN SET FOR THEM.
HOWEVER I AM CONCERNED THAT SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT STAKEHOLDERS
HAVE RAISED. MOST IMPORTANTLY I
THINK AT THAT EACH ELECTRICITY
SUPPLIER. OF THE RIGHT TO MAKE
THEIR OWN DECISION ABOUT WHAT
RESOURCES TO PURCHASE. INCLUDING
TV IN FOR THE CIVIC CENTER OF
RESOURCES THAT. THE THAT THAT
THE FORECAST WOULD BE THE
PROCURE IN THERE ARE P.
SUBMISSION. AS ON SUPPORT FOR OF
RESOURCES THAT DID DID YOU
PROCURE IS EFFICIENT SATISFIED
THERE ARE PS REQUIREMENT. THERE
SHE GIGI TARGET AND OUR
APPLICATION SO. BASICALLY. YOU
KNOW ANY PC THIRTY. I'M GIVEN TO
THE PC BY THIS R. P. STATURE TO
IMPOSE FINES SHOULD BE LIMITED
TO CASES IN WHICH THE
ELECTRICITY PROVIDERS ARE NOT ON
TRACK HIT THIS PERFORMANCE BASED
TARGETS OF HUMAN REYES AT ISSUE
THAT YOU THINK PORTEN AND HELPED
AUTHOR CONTINUE WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO SEE IF WE CAN
KEEP MOVING FORWARD ON THOSE
ISSUES BERMAN SAID TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY. THAT'S VERY INTERESTING I
THOUGHT YOU WERE YOU WERE GONNA
SAY THAT THIS BILL OPENS UP A
LOT A LAWSUIT. TO THE PLANNING
PROCESS. BUT IT'S INTERESTING
THE LAST BILLS A PLANNING BILL.
AND BUT IT REQUIRES CITIES TO
PLAN AND- THIS WILL REQUIRE
UTILITIES AND TO THE INTEREST IN
THE WAY- THE SUPPORT SHIPS ON
THIS ONE YOU KNOW I AM IN FAVOR
OF. A PLANNING AND- SHARING WITH
THE PUBLIC- PLANS ON THAT ISSUE
THAT'S WHY. I THINK WE SHOULD BE
CONSISTENT BUT- CENTER DOT. YES
MY OF MY COLLEGE REFLECTS THAT
THOSE OF US SENATOR. SEE SOME
CHANGES- BY THE TIME HE GETS THE
FLOOR. SENATOR STERN. OKAY-
AGAIN- WE'RE TRYING TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR HERE ON THIS BILL-
PLANNING CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED AND I'LL WE- WE HAVEN'T
HAD A LOT OF TIME TO REALLY
PROPOSED ANYTHING THAT'S WHY WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE A LOT OF
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS BUT- AGAIN-
WORKING TOWARD- SOME OF THE SAME
GOALS THAT WE DISCUSSED IN THE
OTHERS. RELATED TO LIKE TRICITY.
VERSUS GAS AND- I REALLY THINK
THAT WE- HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO
PLAN- THE ENERGY GRID TO THE
FUTURE THAT'S ALL THE ENERGY
GRID SO- WISH THE- AUTHOR LOOK
AT WORKING WITH THIS AND WE'LL
BE KEEPING OUR EYE ON THIS BILL
- AS WELL- DID YOU WANNA MAKE
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS SENTIMENT I
THANK YOU CHAIR WAY SO AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
YOU ALL- AS YOU ALLUDED TO THESE
ELEMENTS CAME IN AFTER- THE
AUTHORS AMENDMENT DEADLINE HAD
EXPIRED SO- AS I UNDERSTAND IT
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH OPPOSITION-
WITH RESPECT TO SOUTHERN
CONSOLIDATED EDISON. WE ARE
WORKING WITH I WOULD MAKE CLEAR
THAT UNDER THE LANGUAGES FOR PC
HAS DISCRETION BUT WE'RE WORKING
WITH THEM CONTINUING THEM TO
FIND WAYS TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS WERE ALSO WORKING WITH
THE CCA'S AND WILL CONTINUE TO
TAKE THEIR INPUT WE DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UTILIZE THE I.
R. P. PROCESS AND NOT THE
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARDS.
WHICH ARE A BIT OF APPLES AND
ORANGES BUT- WE WILL WORK WITH
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF WE WILL-
TAKE THEIR PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
TO THE EXTENT THEY HAVE
SUGGESTIONS GOING FORWARD AND
WILL CONTINUE TO HEAR OUT ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE THIS BILL
RIGHT SO. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. VERY WELL OF J.
THAT VERY MUCH THANK YOU THE
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
EIGHT ONE BY SENATOR MAN THE
MOTION IS IT PASSED TO
APPROPRIATE DO PASS AS AMENDED
OKAY TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS FOR
GIVING. RUSSELL HI WESSEL HI.
SALLY BAKER YEAH HI- BAKER HI A
HOLD ON A SECOND- ARE YOU THE
MOST- THE MOTION WAS MADE BY. BY
SENATOR BAKER WASN'T. NO. WHAT
DID YOU MOVE THE BILL OKAY WE
CAN WE HAVE A MOTION ON THIS
BILL. OKAY WE HAVE MUCH MORE
CENTER STERN WE- START WITH THE-
AND AGAIN THE MOTION. IS THE
PAST APPROPRIATIONS- CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB EIGHT
ONE TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
WESSEL BY WESSEL HI DOLLY. BAKER
I BAKER I EDVARD. DODD I DODD
AYE EGGMAN BY EIGHT MEN I
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ HI HELLO.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG BY MCGUIRE.
MAN MAN I RUBIO. RUBIO I TURN BY
TURN I. SHARE THE BILL HAS AS-
OKAY THANK YOU WELL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS I
WILL MOVE ON TO S. P. EIGHT
EIGHT SEVEN BY SENATOR BAKER-
THIS IS- ITEM THREE SB EIGHT
EIGHT SEVEN. RELATING TO
ELECTRICITY TRANSMISSION
FACILITY PLANNING ANOTHER
PLANNING BILL. THERE BAKER.
HELLO RIGHT REAR. AFTER MR N.
THAT MEMBERS YES THIS IS A
PLANNING BILL NOT PROHIBITING
CITIES TO DO ANYTHING THIS IS A
PLANNING BILL WE CAN'T GET YOUR
ADDRESS AND CLEAN ENERGY OVER
THE NEXT TWENTY YEARS WITHOUT
BUILDING TO TRANSMIT THE
NECESSARY TO DELIVER THAT CLEAN
POWER TO OUR CITIES. SB EIGHTY
PLANNING AND APPROVALS FOR
TRANSMISSION PROJECTS. THE SB
ONE HUNDRED REPORT ESTIMATED
THAT WE NEED TO TRIPLE THE
STATE'S ELECTRIC GENERATION
CAPACITY BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
IN OUR TRANSMISSION GRID IS JUST
NOT PREPARED TO DELIVER THIS
VAST AMOUNT INCREASING CLEAN
ENERGY. I'M THIS PROBLEMS ONLY
GONNA GET WORSE AS
ELECTRIFICATION TRANSPORTATION
AND BUILDINGS INCREASE DEMAND
FOR ELECTRICITY. UNLESS WE BEGIN
TO BUILD THE TRANSMISSION
CAPACITY THAT WE NEED TO HANDLE
THE CLEAN ENERGY GRID OF THE
FUTURE. IT IS URGENT THAT WE GET
STARTED THE BILL NOW BECAUSE
MAJOR NEW TRANSMISSION PROJECTS
OFTEN TAKE TEN YEARS OR MORE TO
BUILD. AND OUR OUR ACCOUNT THAT
THE CASE- CONTROLS TRANSMISSION
PLANNING APPROVALS AND IT'S BEEN
HIGHLY IN THE NEED TO PLAN FOR
TRANSMISSION GROWTH TO MATCH A
RENEWABLE ENERGY BUILD OUT.
HOWEVER THE ONLY A- PROVED ITS
MISSION IF IT IS JUSTIFIED BY
THE FORECAST BEGETS FROM THE CCM
QC. AND THOSE FORECASTS HAVE
BEEN INADEQUATE. BUT THIS BILL
AIMS TO FIX THIS PROBLEM THE
RECENT EFFORTS BY CASE TO
DEVELOP A TWENTY YEAR
TRANSMISSION OUTLOOK WAS AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. SB EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN
WILL ENSURE THESE PRACTICES
CONTINUE AND IMPROVE IT REQUIRES
THE P. C. N. C. C. RIGHT
FORECAST TO CRY SO THE EXTENT AT
LEAST FIFTEEN YEARS IN THE
FUTURE. THOSE FORECAST MUST BE
CONSISTENT WITH ACHIEVING SB ONE
HUNDRED TARGETS FOR RENEWABLE
AND ZERO CARBON RESOURCES. AND
CONSISTENT WITH THEIR BE SCOPING
PLAN TARGETS FOR ECONOMY WIDE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS. THE FORECAST MUST
INCLUDE PLANS TO REDUCE OUR
RELIANCE ON GAS PLANTS THE
EXTENT THAT IS CAUSED BY
TRANSMISSION BOTTLENECKS TO
DELETE THEM AS A LINE WITH THE
STATE'S STRATEGY FOR DEVELOPING
OFFSHORE WIND. AND TO MAKE SURE
WE GET START RIGHT AWAY IT
DIRECTS THE PC TO ASK AYE SO TO
CONSIDER APPROVING AT LEAST ONE
HIGH PRIORITY NO REGRETS
TRANSMISSION PROJECT. DURING THE
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
TRANSMISSION PLANNING PROCESS. I
WANT TO QUICKLY ADDRESS CONCERNS
SOME PEOPLE RAISED ABOUT THE
BILL. THERE'S BEEN SUGGESTIONS
THE BILL REQUIRES ALL GAS POWER
PLANTS TO SHUT DOWN BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE. AND THAT IS VERY
MUCH NOT ACCURATE. THE BILL JUST
REQUIRES A PC'S RESOURCE
FORECASTS NOT TO RELY ON GAS
PLANTS BECAUSE- OF TRANSMISSION
CONSTRAINTS. I'M HAPPY CAN TO
DISCUSS ANY CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT
WE MAINTAIN RELIABILITY. AND
DON'T CREATE AN EXCESSIVELY
EXPENSIVE MANDATE. THE BILL JUST
SAYING THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
THERE'S ENOUGH CLEAN ENERGY
ELSEWHERE ON THE GRID. WE SHOULD
NOT NEED TO RUN THE GAS PLANTS
JUST BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T SIX
TRANSMISSION BOTTLENECKS LET'S
FIX THOSE TRANSMISSION
BOTTLENECKS. WE'RE ON A PATH FOR
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF MEGAWATTS
OF NEW CLEAN ENERGY ELECTRICITY
GENERATION BUT WITHOUT
COMPATIBLE EFFORTS TO EXPAND OUR
TRANSMISSION CAPACITY THE
SEVERAL FAIR TO FAIR WILL FAIL
TO MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS. I AM
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR HELPING TO IMPROVE
THE BILL. BEYOND THE ITEMS
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE ANALYSIS WERE
ALSO ADDRESSING ADDING A DATE BY
WHEN THE BETTER FORECAST WILL BE
REQUIRED. AND WE WILL BE
STRIKING A REFERENCE TO CARBS
INVOLVEMENT IN THE TRANSMISSION
PLANNING PROCESS. PROCESS AT
CARBS REQUEST SINCE CARP IS NOT
CURRENTLY INVOLVED. I WANT TO
THANK A BIPARTISAN AND BICAMERAL
GROUP THIS RT AT HONEST CO
AUTHORS AND- THE GROUPS
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SOCIOCULTURAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL LABOUR'S.
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA UTILITY
UNIONS INTERNATIONAL OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS. MEMO SPARK
ANDMANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. OKAY VERY WELL WHAT WILL
GO TO- SPEAKERS. WE HAVE AN
ORGANIZED PRESENTATIONS SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT THERE ARE. TWO
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT WILL SO WILL
CUT THEIR TIME. AFTER EACH SHOW
TO BE A MINUTE AND A HALF FROM
MICHAEL COLEMAN. AT A MINUTE AND
A HALF FOR STEVE MIGHT. I WILL
START WITH MICHAEL COLEMAN IF
YOU SEE THERE HERE ON THE LINE.
YEAH HELLO I'M ON THE LINE CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK YES. CONTACT ON
MY NAME IS MICHAEL HOLDEN I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY PROGRAM. ONE NINE THAT
COULD BE RECORDING SENATE BILL
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN- AS WE UNDERGO
OUR CLEAN ENERGY TRANSITION
REGION ALL RECOGNIZED.
GENERATING POWER AND NOT GETTING
THE POWER TO WHERE IT IS NEEDED
WHY IS IT. GOING TO MEAN NEW
TRANSMISSION. ON ALL YOU- YOU
WOULD HAVE ASKED ME EIGHTEEN
MONTHS AGO I WOULD HAVE THE
FADING INTO THE LIKE THAT- I
INCORRECTLY ASSUMED THAT THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO REACH CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS THE TIME EXPANSION
OF THE EXISTING TRANSMISSION.
HOWEVER I TAKEN THE OPPORTUNITY
TO LOOK AT THE NUMBERS ARE
CLOSELY NINE OUT OF THE COUNTRY
ALL. I CAN CONFIDENTLY CONCLUDE
THAT EVEN IF THEY WERE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO GET NOTHING LOCAL.
WE'RE STILL GOING TO NEED A
TRANSMISSION LINE. IN ORDER TO
BUILD IS OUT OF PORTABLE LEAD TO
DO TO HIS FAMILY WE'RE GOING TO
NEED A PLAN NOTHING IS GOING TO
HAVE TO START NOW. THE CASE WHO
SHOULD BE APPLAUDED FOR ALL OF
THEIR INNOVATIVE WORK IN THERE
NOW TWENTY YEAR OUTLOOK PLAN.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT NOVEL
DOCUMENT. UNKNOWN IS THE
INTERAGENCY COORDINATION AT THE
PARK AT ALL I AM OUT. BY THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD EXPRESS TO
USE AS WELL SB EIGHTY SEVEN IS
THE BEST VEHICLE FOR THE CHAMBER
AND PROVIDE THE IMPORTANT.
CONTRIBUTION PLANNING. WITH THAT
I SUPPORT THE BILL AND I HUMBLY
FOR YOUR ITEM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW WE'LL GO TO STEVE. MY
TAKE. THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER
I'M ON THE PHONE AND- I
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY- MY
NAME IS STEVEN TANK- I'M AN
ELECTRIC UTILITY CONSULTANT WITH
MORE THAN THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE- DIRECTING ENERGY
LOAD FORECASTING INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLANNING TRANSMISSION
PLANNING. ALL AT A SPECIFIC GAS
ELECTRIC COMPANY. FOR THE LAST
SIX YEARS I'VE BEEN AN INDUSTRY
CONSULTANT WITH A FOCUS ON HOW
TO PLAN AND OPERATE THE
ELECTRIC. RESPONSIBLY AND
ECONOMICALLY AND I HAVE
EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE WORKING
WITH THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THE ENERGY COMMISSION
AND THEN. CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
SYSTEM OPERATOR. SENATE BACKER
AND- HOLDEN MENTION- WE NORMALLY
DEVELOPMENT IN THE YEARS TO COME
I IS GOING TO BE SIGNIFICANTLY
THE STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS
HOWEVER CALIFORNIA'S NOT BEEN
KEEPING PACE IN APPROVING THAT
NEEDED NEW TRANSMISSION.
ESPECIALLY THOSE LONG LEAD TIME
TRANSMISSION PROJECTS TO DELIVER
POWER FROM RENEWABLE RESOURCES.
TO THE LOAD CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. SB EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN
THE PROBLEM IN SEVERAL IMPORTANT
WAYS FIRST PLAY ENDING THE STATE
AGENCY ELECTRIC LOAD FORECASTING
RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT PLANS TO
FIFTEEN YEARS OR MORE INTO THE
FUTURE. THE CURRENT TEN YEAR
HORIZONS ARE GOOD FOR FOCUSING
ON GENERATION RESOURCES THAT ARE
NEEDED EXTRA LEADERS SEVEN YEARS
BUT THOSE POOR CAN NOT SHOW
SIGNIFICANT- RESOURCES THAT WILL
BE NEEDED. FOR ELECTRIFICATION
THERE'S INTO THE FUTURE. THERE'S
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
APPRECIATE YOU WEIGH IN AND-
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO IN
OPPOSITION AND PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON THE BILL
ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION TO I MEAN IN SUPPORT.
OF ITEM THREE SB EIGHT EIGHT
SEVEN. YES HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND
- MISTER CHAIRMAN SCOTT WHAT
SHOULD BE HAVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
ALLEGE WORKERS IN THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THE NEXT
SPEAKER ANYONE ELSE. THANK YOU
MELISSA CORTEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
SUPPORT OF A MAN WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR ON LANGUAGE AROUND
THE ELIMINATION OF GAS THANK
YOU. THANK SECURE MEMBERS JOHN
WHITE WITH THE CLEAN POWER
CAMPAIGN A BILL NEEDS SOME WORK
BUT WE SUPPORT THE LEGISLATURE
GIVING STRONGER DIRECTION THE PC
ON THIS ISSUE AND- AS FOR APPLE.
THANK YOU. NOW WILL GO TO- THE
MODERATOR AND ASK FOR SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT OF ITEM THREE S. B.
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN. MODERATOR
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE ABOUT EIGHT IN Q. ONE
FORTY ONE FORTY FIVE PEOPLE HAVE
. MACINNES RETURN MEMBERS- JAMES
THE RECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL LABORS AND WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORTER EIGHT EIGHT
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. THANK YOU LINE FORTY
PLEASE CALL ASK. HELLO AN
INVASION CAMANCHE UPON BEHALF OF
SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION- LARGE SCALE SOLAR
ASSOCIATION AND EDP RENEWABLES
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
. THANK YOU LINE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS MAKE IT A
KARATE WITH ENERGYHE IS
SUPPORTIVE SB EIGHTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER.
THANK. YOU I'M SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOU CAN NUMBER BE A
CRANE CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY STORAGE
ALLIANCE THE PART OF THE MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
. THANK YOU LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
LUCIANA CRATER I AM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROJECT ASSISTANT
FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
DIVISION AT THE FAN DANIEL
CASSADY IN BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS HERE IN CONCORD SB EIGHT
EIGHT SEVEN. NEXT BIGGER. THANK
YOU I TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JANICK **** FOR TREATING
THE SILICON VALLEY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. THANK YOU
LINE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. MISTER CHAIRMAN MICHAEL LINES
ON BEHALF OF THREE RIVERS ENERGY
DEVELOPMENT IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER.
THANK YOU LINE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS RAY BACA
ENGINEERING CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION AND WE STAND IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT EIGHT
SEVEN. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE CALL HAD. THIS IS
SANTIAGO CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY SEVEN. OKAY NEXT
BIGGER. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU OKAY
WILL GO TO AN ORGANIZED
PRESENTATION IN OPPOSITION LED
BY CHANCE MONEY JONES ONE
SPEAKER THREE MINUTES IF HE'S
HERE OR ON THE PHONE. THE PHONE
. YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES WELCOME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH VISION GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS ON JAZZ NINETY JONES
WITH THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS WE ARE OPPOSED SB
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN- OUR MEMBERS
INCLUDE UTILITY SCALE SOLAR WIND
GEOTHERMAL BIOMASS CLEAN NATURAL
GAS ENERGY STORAGE AND
INDEPENDENT TRANSMISSION
PROJECTS WE ARE ACTIVELY ENGAGED
IN BEATING CALIFORNIA'S
GREENHOUSE GAS GOALS BY BUILDING
OUT THE RESOURCES- TO MEET
FUTURE DATE NOW I. P. SHARES THE
AUTHOR'S INTEREST IN ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE NECESSARY
TRANSMISSION AVAILABLE TO
DELIVER CLEAN RESOURCES. HOWEVER
IT IS IMPORTANT THESE PROJECTS
ARE COST EFFECTIVE AND ONCE
DEVELOPED IN A TIMELY MANNER WE
BELIEVE THAT S. B. EIGHT H.
SEVEN MILLION HE DID NOT
ACCELERATE. SHOULD. SEE BILL
WOULD GO INTO A ONE ONE AT
TWENTY TWO THREE- TWO WEEKS
LATER THE BILL REQUIRES THE P.
USE TO REQUEST THE- OF APPROVE.
TO TRANSFER PRICE DESIGNED TO
REPLACE GAS GENERATION AND LOCAL
CONSTRAINED AREAS OTHER NOTE
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS LCAS. THERE
IS NO COST EFFECTIVENESS
CRITERIA ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
REQUIREMENT. IS NOT CLEAR HOW
THE QC OR THE I SO COULD
IMPLEMENT THE REQUIRED PUBLIC
COMMENT THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS IN A TWO WEEK. TIME
CALVET SO ALREADY HAS A
FINANCIAL UP L. C. A. PROCESS TO
EVALUATE- THE NEED FOR SUCH
PLANTS. KALISTO CURRENTLY HAS A
TEN YEAR PLANNING SO. CHANGING
IT TO FIFTY. REQUIRE EIGHTY
BURKE AND THEN IT WHICH MADE IT
HAD TO DO TIME. THIS BILL DOES
REQUIRE THE AND ELIMINATION OF
GAS FACILITIES BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE SEE HE FOR HOWEVER
ALL CPUC I. R. P. STUDY SHOWS
GAS FACILITIES WILL BE
NECESSARY. FOR RELIABILITY
THROUGH TWENTY FORTY FIVE THEY
WILL RUN LESS BUT WILL BE
REQUIRED TO MEET GROUP
RELIABILITY NEEDS UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES. SOME OF THESE
PLANS ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
EVALUATING RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS
AND HYDROGEN AS FUEL SOURCES
OTHERS ARE UTILIZING CARBON.
CARBON CAPTURE AND UTILIZATION
SEVERAL THESE AS FOR READY USE
ONSITE BATTERY STORAGE IS A
COMPONENT RELIABILITY OPERATION.
SB EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN HAS AN
ASSUMPTION THAT THERE IS A
HIGHER PRIORITY TO ELIMINATING
THESE PLANTS AND LCAS RATHER
THAN FOCUS ON TRANSMISSION
FACILITIES TO ACCESS. NEW CLEAN
RESOURCES ELSEWHERE CAUTION
SHOULD BE EXERCISED IN
LEGISLATING PLAN- TRANSMISSION
PLANNING OUTCOMES TRANSMISSIONS
SERVING CALIFORNIA IS
INTERCONNECTED TO THE ENTIRE
WEST. DECISIONS BASED UPON A
TRANSPARENT PROCESS SOLID
ENGINEERING AND COST
EFFECTIVENESS PRINCIPLES THAT
ARE ALL CONSISTENT. WITH THE
LAWS OF. D. AS A DENTAL FIVE
THERE IS ROOM TO CAN BE MADE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH
AUTHOR BUT WE RESPECTIVELY
OPPOSED TO PROCESS CONTEMPLATED
IN SB EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING OVER.
THANK YOU. K. VERY WELL WE'LL GO
TO A SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION YOU
CAN LIMIT YOUR COMMENT YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON THE BILL
NO ONE HERE WILL GO TO THE
PHONES MODERATOR PLEASE Q.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO ASK THE EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU. OKAY VERY GOOD- NO NONE AT
ALL NONE IN OPPOSITION. OKAY
WELL CAN I HAVE NO COMMENT
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE ANYONE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE. THE
CENTRE BORCHERS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. I'VE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CHAT WITH FOLKS-
ON FRANKLIN BOTH SIDES OF THIS
ISSUE AND- I WANTED TO POSE IF I
MAY THROUGH THE CHAIR- SOME
QUESTIONS TO THE AUTHOR OF THE
APPROPRIATE YES. THANK YOU. SO
I'M TRYING TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
THIS IS CONSOLIDATED INTO A
DIGESTIBLE FORM I THINK WE ALL
KNOW THAT. AS WE IN THE
SPECIALLY AS WE MOVE IN THE
DIRECTION OF- FLOATING- WIND.
GENERATION WHICH I THINK SHOULD
BE THE DIRECTION THAT WE ARE
GOING AT LEAST FOR A COMPONENT
OF OUR ENERGY NEEDS. WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO DEAL WITH-
ELECTRIFICATION INFRASTRUCTURE
TO MOVE THAT TYPE. OF-
TRANSMISSION. BUT I SO IT SEEMS
THAT THIS DOCUMENT IS MORE OF A
DIRECTIONAL POLICY DOCUMENT. TO
THE P. YOU SEE. TO MAKE THE
NECESSARY- POLICY AND-
ADMINISTRATIVE. INVESTMENTS TO
MAKE CERTAIN THAT THAT WE ARE
KEEPING ELECTRIFICATION AT THE
FOREFRONT OF BECAUSE THESE
THINGS TAKE YEARS SOMETIMES
DECADES. TO PUT INTO EFFECT. I
WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN IN MAYBE
YOU CAN COMMENT PLEASE. IN WHAT
FASHION DOES THIS INTERFERE OR
CHALLENGE FOR OUR CREE BARRIERS
FOR OUR TRADITIONAL EXTRACTION
IN USAGE OF FOSSIL FUELS BECAUSE
I THINK EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS
THAT ESPECIALLY AS WE'VE SEEN
WHAT'S HAPPENED WITH YOUR CREAM-
THAT. CALIFORNIANS MOVING-
DRAMATICALLY IN THE
DIVERSIFICATION ROUTE BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T GO GREEN OVERNIGHT AND
IT'S GOING TO BE IN WE NEED TO
MAKE CERTAIN THAT WE STILL HAVE
A COMPONENT. OF OUR ENERGY NEEDS
SATISFIED BY SOME OF THE MORE
TRADITIONAL- ALSO FUEL
EXTRACTION. SO MY QUESTION TO
THE AUTHORS CAN YOU EXPLAIN
EXACTLY HOW THIS DOCUMENT IF IT
DOES- SO AT ALL. INTERFERES OR
TAKES A POLICY POSITION THAT
WOULD HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE
TRADITIONAL EXTRACTION
INDUSTRIES. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT AND I JUST WANNA
REITERATE THAT THIS. IN THIS
BILL THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT TO
STOP. USING GAS PLANTS DOESN'T
FORCE ANY SHUTDOWNS- WHAT DOES
IT SAY THAT IF THERE'S CLEAN
ENERGY AVAILABLE ON THE GRID.
THEN LET'S BUILD THE
TRANSMISSION TO GET IT WHERE IT
NEEDS TO GO. SO WE SHOULDN'T SAY
WE NEED TO RELY ON THE GAS
PLANTS AFTER THAT. I'M THE IF
THERE'S CLEAN ENERGY AVAILABLE
ELSEWHERE ON THE GRID SO IT
REALLY YEAH YOU THINK YOUR POINT
ABOUT PLANNING ABSOLUTELY. IT IS
ABOUT PLANNING A FROM THE P. YOU
SEE I'LL TRUST ONE OTHER-
QUESTION ISN'T THAT WAS RAISED
IN MY CLOTHES- BUT I THINK USE
HEARD FROM ALL THE VOICES IN
SUPPORT THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
THAT LONG TERM PLANNING HORIZON
AND IT DOES YES AGAIN DOES NOT
FORCE. SHUTDOWN OF ANY GAS
RESOURCES OKAY. FORGIVE ME FOR
FURTHER EMPHASIZING THIS POINT.
IS THERE ANYTHING IN THIS TYPE
OF DOCUMENT. THAT WOULD INSTRUCT
THE P. YOU SEE FOR THEM ACTING
ON AT THEIR OWN BEHEST. THAT IF
THERE ARE TWO SOURCES OF ENERGY.
EXISTING SIMULTANEOUSLY THAT ONE
WOULD BE SEURE IN ONE WOULD BE
SUBORDINATE BY VIRTUE OF THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. NO ARE THE
FOCUS IS ON PREPARING
TRANSMISSIONS THAT WE CAN
DELIVER CLEAN ENERGY AS IT IS
BUILT- SO YEAH THE ANSWER
QUESTIONS NO- IT DOES NOT JUST%
RIGHT NOW WE CAN BILL OF THE
CLEAN ENERGY WE WANT WE JUST
CAN'T GET IT TO WHERE IT NEEDS
TO BE. AND SO THEREFORE WE'RE
GONNA STOP BUILDING AND IF YOU
LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED IN GERMANY
IT'S THE SAME THING THAT USED UP
ALL MOST THEY'RE GOOD- YOU KNOW
THEY'RE EASY TO BUILD- AT
LOCATIONS AND NOW THEY'RE CLEAN
ENERGY- BUILDINGS ACTUALLY GOING
DOWN. ON AND WE'RE TRYING TO
AVOID THAT MAKE SURE WE PLANTS
WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE
TRANSMISSION ALL THIS OFF SHORE
WIND ALL THIS THAT WE WANT TO
BUILD. ON WHAT I CAN DO A BILL
THAT UNLESS WE HAVE THIS IN A
LONG RANGE PLANNING HORIZON.
OKAY THIS IS CERTAINLY A TOUCHY
TOPIC AS YOU COULD IMAGINE I
REPRESENT THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND WE STILL HAVE. BY I KNOW OF
PLAYERS. IN THE TRADITIONAL.
EXTRACTION INDUSTRY. THEY THEY-
LITERALLY ARE THE VANGUARD OF
ENVIRONMENTAL- A BY THIS WHEN IT
COMES TO ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND LAWS. AND I KNOW THAT WE ARE
MOVING IN THIS DIRECTION OF
ELECTRICAL AND SOLAR AND- WIND.
AND MAKING THIS THE NEXT
EVOLUTION OF CALIFORNIANS-
ENERGY SYSTEM- SO I WANTED TO BE
VERY CLEAR THAT. AS I SUPPORT
THIS TODAY IF THIS DOES CHANGE.
IN A FASHION WHERE. WE ARE
FORCIBLY SUBORDINATING. OUR
TRADITIONAL EXTRACTION INDUSTRY
OF. REGULAR IN A REGULATORY
SYSTEM AWARDED MINISTRY TO
SYSTEM I DON'T THINK I'D BE IN A
POSITION TO SUPPORT OF IT
APPEARS THE WAY IT'S WRITTEN
RIGHT NOW. THAT THIS IS SIMPLY
EVOLVING THE PUC'S ARE- IT
MINISTRY OF PAPERWORK AND- IT'S
RESOURCE ALLOCATION DOING WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE ESPECIALLY IN
THE FIELD OF OFFSHORE WIND. AND
I THINK WITHOUT BEING IN MIND
I'D BE WILLING TO SUPPORT THIS
TODAY ASSUMING IT DOES NOT
CHANGE MOVING FORWARD. BOB
SENATOR DOLLY. MY UP THANK YOU.
HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR
SO RESULT. TURNER'S SECOND CA
FIRST I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR IN
THE BILL FOR THE GETS SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN WAY OVERDUE
CALIFORNIA WE ARE OVER
PRODUCING- GREEN ENERGY AND
AREAS AND WE'RE ACTUALLY
EXPORTING IT TO OTHER STATES AND
OUR RATE PAYERS ARE PAYING FOR
IT- TO THE TUNE OF ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR THERE ARE
RATE PAYERS ARE PAYING AND WE'RE
SENDING ENERGY TO ARIZONA AND
OTHER PLACES SO I LIKE THAT PART
OF THE BILL. A COUPLE QUESTIONS
THOUGH ONE OF THE QUESTIONS IS-
MUNICIPALITIES THAT- BY ENERGY
BY THAT ENERGY- FROM. THE SUPPLY
THAT'S AVAILABLE IN. WITHIN
THEIR GRID AREA. AND THOSE ARE
PURCHASE POWER AGREEMENTS. AND
THAT SOME OF THOSE AGREEMENTS-
ART. SOMETIMES TWENTY TO THIRTY
YEARS LONG SO IF YOU. ARE A E.
CCA AND YOU'VE ACQUIRED POWER
FROM. WHATEVER SOURCE IT IS AND
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN THERE'S NOW
A NEW TRANSMISSION LINE. IT
DOESN'T NEED YOUR POWER IN YOUR
BRING IN THAT POWER FROM
SOMEWHERE ELSE. THE UTILITY IS
STILL ON THE HOOK FOR THAT
PURCHASE POWER AGREEMENT THAT
WAS AVAILABLE. AT THE TIME WHEN
THEY HAD TO SECURE POWER FOR
THEIR CUSTOMERS WHAT HAPPENS TO
THOSE- CONTRACTS- GOING FORWARD
IF THE TRANSMISSION LINES BUILT.
AND THEY DON'T NEED THAT POWER
ANYMORE. WELL FIRST OF ALL
THANKS FOR FIRST PARTNER
COMMENTS AND I'M PRETTY SURE NO
YOU'VE BEEN ON THIS
TRANSMISSION. ISSUE IN THE PAST
. I THINK THE ANSWER IS THAT I
DON'T GAS FROM EXPERTS. I THINK
ONE OF THE ANSWER IS THAT- ALL
THIS ENERGY CAN BE NEEDED RIGHT
OUT THERE I DON'T SEE A FIRST
YEAR. A SITUATION WHERE IT WON'T
BE BUT LET ME ASK STEVE ME TAG
TO SEE IF HE HAS A COMMENT ON
THAT. A QUESTION. SURE THANK
YOU. YES I THINK- THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT THE- IDEA THAT- THERE IS.
A GROWING NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
NEW CLEAN ENERGY AND THIS-
TRANSMISSION THAT'S- INSPIRED BY
THIS BILL WILL ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE. THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT-
EXISTING. POWER PURCHASE WAS
MADE TO GO AWAY- HOPEFULLY WE'LL
STILL BE ECONOMIC IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT BUT- NEW
TRANSMISSION. FOR NEW GENERATION
. HE DID. OKAY BUT THAT'S NOT
REALLY AN ANSWER MY QUESTION
BECAUSE THERE ARE CONTRACTS OUT
THEN I'M OUT I KNOW THIS BECAUSE
WE WERE FACING THAT SO I'M JUST
GONNA I'M SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY BUT I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
AN ANSWER WHEN WE COME BACK TO
THE TO THE FLOOR BECAUSE I'M AN
ASSET TO WIN AGAIN BECAUSE IT'S
VERY CRITICAL YUP THE COST TO
THE CONSUMER THAT ALREADY ON THE
HOOK FOR SOME OTHERS- SOURCE OF
ENERGY. ON THAT SO I THINK IT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AND I
HEARD THAT BEFORE I'M ALL FOR.
THE OTHER THERE'S ONE OTHER
QUESTION ONE ISSUE THAT. YOU'RE
FORCING THE PC TO MAKE THE
DECISION ON TWO LINES. AND IT
HAS BEEN AN AMENDMENT ON THAT.
POINT COMMENSURATE YEAH SO IT
JUST DIDN'T GET INTO PRINT FOR
THE ORIGINALLY WE DID HAVE THAT
CONCEPT IN THE BILL- BUT IT HAS
BEEN AMENDED TO. SAY THAT THE
CASE SO- CONSIDER APPROVING AT
LEAST ONE. THE WAY WE WENT FOR
THE LANGUAGE OF APPROVED AT
LEAST TO HIGH PARTY PROJECTS TO
CONSIDER APPROVING AT LEAST ONE
. OKAY WELL ALONG I DIDN'T SEE
THAT AMENDMENT BUT ALONG THOSE
LINES. YOU KNOW IT. WE SHOULD
LOOK AT CALIFORNIA'S A WHOLE AND
FIGURE OUT WHERE WE'RE OVER
PRODUCING. GREEN ENERGY AND WE
NEEDED TO GET TO SOMEWHERE ELSE
THAT SHOULD BE THE PRIORITY THAT
SHOULD BE DONE BY THE CPUC.
WHICH UNFORTUNATELY HASN'T BEEN
DONE THAT'S WHY YOU'RE RUNNING
THIS BILL TO SAY HEY. WE NEED TO
GO DO THAT SO. I'M THOSE ARE THE
THINGS I'M GONNA BE LOOKING FOR
WHEN WE COME BACK- SO. WHAT'S
THE PRIORITY WHICH AREAS- THAT
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY ARE OVER
GENERATING. AND GETTING INTO
AREAS WHERE WE DON'T HAVE THAT
SAME- ABILITY TO GENERATE SO
THAT WE- WE CAN ACTUALLY BALANCE
THE GRID. WITH GREEN ENERGY. AT
THE SAME TIME MAKING SURE THAT
WE DON'T LEAVE SOMEBODY WAS
STRANDED ASSETS- THAT A PROCURED
ENERGY. FOR LONG HAUL AND I
THINK IF THAT WAS THE CASE THE
SPEAKER PLANT FOLKS. AND WE HAVE
TO MAKE THEM WHOLE THEY BUILT
THESE PLANTS. AND INVESTED MONEY
EXPECTING. A CONTRACT SOMEWHERE
IF THAT CHANGES THEN WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE MADE
WHOLE. THANK YOU AND AGAIN I
GOTTA COME INTO AT THE EXISTING
CONTRACTS ARE GOING TO BE
HONORABLE CLARIFY WITH YOU BUT
DON'T FEEDBACK I'VE GOTTEN. FROM
FOLKS WHO WORK WITH EXISTING
CONTRACTS ARE GOING TO BE
HONORED JUST WHEN YOU NEED TO
BUY NEW ENERGY. THEN REMOVING
THE TRANSMISSION CONSTRAINTS
GIVES YOU MORE CHOICES. AND THE
SECOND PART OF A SAID ABSOLUTELY
I NEED WE NEED TO DO THAT MAP.
AND I THINK THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FOR EXAMPLE VIA. THE BIG BENEFIT
SURE OF THIS BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
WE LIMIT TRANSITION FROM THOSE
AREAS- THAT PREVENT THEM FROM
SELLING CLEAN ENERGY TO
CUSTOMERS AND- IN CITY SO. A
GROUP BOTH THROUGH THAT WE DO
NEED TO DO THAT PLANNING AND I
THINK THE SENSE OF I WILL BE A
BENEFIT SURE OF THAT. AND IF I
MIGHT SUGGEST IF YOU REALLY WANT
TO BE PULLED. WHO WOULDN'T STOP.
ALLOWING GENERATION TO BE
PROCURED IN AREAS WHERE WE HAVE.
TOO MUCH ALREADY. THAT WOULD
REALLY BE BOLD BECAUSE THEN. WE
COULD ACTUALLY DRIVE THE COST
DOWN FOR CUSTOMERS IN
CALIFORNIA. THESE ARE GETTING A
TAX REBATE. ON BUILDING THEIR
SOLAR INCENTIVIZE FORD OR WIND.
AND THERE'S NO NEED FOR THAT
AREA SO. IT'S A MATTER OF
BALANCING THAT GREAT OUT SO
APPRECIATE YOUR BILL AND LOOKING
FOR THE DETAILS WHEN WE GET TO
THE NEXT COMMITTEE. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE. BILL MOTION BY
SENATOR STERN BACK IN IF I COULD
JUST ADD COMMENTS BECAUSE I KNOW
WE'VE GONE THROUGH- A REVIEW OF
THIS PROCESS VERY THOROUGH
CIRCUITS IN THIS BILL GENERALLY
IS- QUITE. NONSPECIFIC ON A LOT
OF ISSUES AND I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE DOES NEED TO GET
SPECIFIC WHEN IT COMES TO- HOW
HOW WE INVEST IN PLANNING
BECAUSE AGAIN ALL OF THIS. HAS A
RETURN ON COST. I DO WANNA BEGIN
BY POINTING OUT THE AMENDMENT
THAT WAS- PROPOSED AND IF I CAN
JUST CORRECT. SENATOR BAKER A
BIT ON THE AMENDMENT ALL READ IT
JUST SO IT'S CLEAR EVERYBODY'S
MINE WHAT THE AMENDMENT IS THE
FIRST AMENDMENT. WAS REFERENCED-
AND I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE IT'S
READ ACCURATELY INTO THE RECORD.
IT DELETES REFERENCE TO
REQUIRING THE CHI SO TO APPROVE
TWO OR MORE PROJECTS. TWO OR
MORE- WITH LANGUAGE THAT ALLOWS
A CASUAL TO DETERMINE WHETHER
PROJECTS NEED TO BE APPROVED FOR
INCORPORATION INTO THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SLASH TWENTY THREE
TRANSMISSION PLAN. AND JUST
GENERALLY WE DON'T HAVE ANY-
COST ANALYSIS ON THIS AND I
THINK THAT IS AGAIN WE HAVE TO
BE VERY SENSITIVE TO HOW. WE
INVEST IN OUR- RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO THAT WITH THAT WE
LIMIT- THAT WE REALLY MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS IN TERMS OF BENEFIT
TO THE SYSTEM COST BENEFIT
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFIT. AND OFTEN
TIMES A WEEK WE THINK LESS ABOUT
THE COST BENEFIT WHICH IS SET
RATES CAR WASH CORRUPTION YOU
MEANT YOU MENTIONED. A COASTAL
WIND POWER BAND I JUST RAISES
LOTS OF RED FLAGS TO ME BECAUSE
CITING- WIND POWER IN THE
CALIFORNIA COASTLINE IS GOING TO
BE A VERY DIFFICULT THING.
ESPECIALLY FROM MY EXPERIENCE IN
THE COASTAL COMMISSION AND HOW
TO CREATE THOSE CONNECTIONS TO
THE MAINLAND. IT'S GOING TO BE
EXTREMELY EXTREMELY COSTLY. AND
SOMEWHAT OF A RISK- SO. A SECOND
AB MENTIONED ARE WE GONNA START-
A PLANNING FOR THAT REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER THERE'S AN IMPACT OR
NOT I THINK WE SHOULD KNOW THAT
AS LEGISLATURE AND I HOPE. THAT
WE COULD COME TO SOME
UNDERSTANDING BEFORE THIS BILL
IS SENT TO THE GOVERNOR. ON WHAT
WE MEAN BY- THE LONG TERM
PLANNING AND OF COURSE THE
ADJUSTMENT- REQUIRED ALLOWS FOR
THAT PLANNING PROCESS TO BE
UNDERTAKEN BUT AT SOME POINT. WE
HAVE TO TALK ABOUT BUT WERE WERE
ASKING. THE PETER YOU KNOW CRY
SO. AND THE CPUC TO DO HERE SO
AGAIN ASIDE ASIDE LIKE TO AFFORD
MY COLLEAGUES THE ABILITY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THEIR BILLS.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL MOVING
FORWARD AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
START TO ADDRESS KIND OF THE
FINER TUNING OF THE DETAILS OF
THE BILL- IF THERE ARE NO MORE
COMMENTS. DID YOU WANNA MAKE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS NO THANK YOU
YOUR CLARIFICATION- I THINK
ADDRESSED ONE OF THE POINTS THAT
WAS RAISED I APPRECIATE YOU
STATING THAT AMENDMENT AND FOR
ALL THE WORK ON THE BILL.
ESPECIALLY AS FROM ABOUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- CLERK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION. FRAZIER
WAS OUR MOTION. THERE WAS A
MOTION BY SENATOR STERN. THANK
CHAIR. SB THIRTY TH SB EIGHT
SEVEN BY SENATOR SPECTER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL FIVE
WESSEL HI DOLLY HI. DOLLY I
BAKER. BAKER I FORGES. PORGES I
. BRADFORD DODD. DODD AYE EGGMAN
HI. EGGMAN I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
GROW. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
MCGUIRE. MAN MAN I RUBIO HI
RUBIO AYE STERN. STERN FIVE.
SURE THAT'S ELEVEN AS OKAY WE'LL
KEEP THE- ELEVEN YOU SAID ELEVEN
. ZERO YEAH ELEVEN ZERO WITH
SOME- MEMBERS ABSENT WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
. AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO CENTER
STERN ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB ELEVEN
SIXTY FOUR- CENTER SIR WHEN
pYOU MISTER CHAIR OF BEFORE BEGIN
I'D LIKE TO FIRST ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS STARTING MIDDLE PAGE
FIVE. I'M HAPPY GO THROUGH THOSE
DETAILS WITH YOU ALL BUT- FIRST
AMENDMENT SWAPS OUT THE AIR
RESOURCE BOARD FOR THE ENERGY
COMMISSION PREPARING THE REPORT
IN THE SECOND EXTEND THE
DEADLINE FOR THE REPORTS- FROM.
JULY TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR-
MEMBERS. SB ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR
PERMANENT PROMOTES CALIFORNIA'S
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION GOALS. BY ENSURING
THAT WE'RE GONNA TAKE SOME
INITIAL STEPS TO DEVELOP
ELECTRONIC REGISTRIES. RACK AC
HEATING H. BACK EQUIPMENT SALES
TO INSURANCE DOLLARS COMPLY WITH
PERMANENT CODE REQUIREMENTS AND
PROVIDE TITLE TWENTY FOUR ENERGY
CODE COMPLIANCE DOCUMENTATION.
SENSUALLY THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF H. BACK UNITS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA NOT BE
INSTALLED PROPERLY THEY'RE NOT
GOING THROUGH THE PROPER
PERMITTING PROCESS WE DON'T
RECORD ACTUALLY KNOW WHERE
THEY'RE BEING INSTALLED- AND
WHEN THEY'RE INSTALLED
IMPROPERLY SOMETIMES YOU CAN
GET- INCREASED ENERGY USE UP TO
TWENTY OR THIRTY PERCENT- PER
HOUSEHOLD- WE'RE WE WERE FINDING
THAT. TELL TWENTY FOUR IS ALSO
NOT BEING COMPLIED WITH VERY
OFTEN REFERRED TO AS LITTLE AS
15% OF THE TIME- AND SO WHEN YOU
HAVE UN PERMITTED H. FAQ
INSTALLATIONS GOING ON THEY'RE
DONE WITH. POOR QUALITY- WITH
POOR EFFICIENCY- THE RATEPAYERS
OF PEOPLE ACTUALLY NEED WILL AIR
IN THEIR PLACES TO SURVIVE OR
EVER HOTTER SUMMERS AND- WINTERS
AS WELL- ARE GETTING LEFT AT THE
BACK. SO IT'S TIME TO PROVIDE
SOME CLEAR DIRECTION TO SEE SEE
THAT THEY'RE EMPOWERED TO MOVE
AND MOVE QUICKLY ON TAKING
AGGRESSIVE ACTIONS TO IMPROVE
ENERGY CODE COMPLIANCE. WE'RE
DIRECTING AGENCIES TO COME BACK
TO US. WITH FORTY FOUR PROPOSALS
THE RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF
INDUSTRY AND CONTRACTORS AND
LOCAL BUILDING OFFICIALS. AND
IDENTIFY BUDGET NEEDS
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS AND ANY
ACTIONS THAT ARE NEEDED OVERCOME
BARRIERS WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF MY CO SPONSORS. OF
THE CALIFORNIA PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL SCOTT WELCH AND THOMAS
LOW WITH THE WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL SHEET METAL WORKERS TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL YES WE
HAVE TO ORGANIZE PRESENTATIONS
IN SUPPORT. THE NEW. ENOUGH SO
WE WILL GRANT- THE SPEAKERS. IN
IN SUPPORT EACH A MINUTE AND A
HALF FOR THE ORGANIZED
PRESENTATIONS MISTER WELCH YOUR
FIRST ONLINE MISTER CHAIRMAN A
MEMBER SCOTT WHAT SHOULD BE A
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE
TRADES COUNCIL. TITLE TWENTY
FOUR IS THE WAY THAT WE IN
CALIFORNIA- INSURER ENERGY
EFFICIENT BUILDINGS IN THE WAY
THAT WE SURE THAT WE REDUCE OUR
OUR OUR CARBON OUTPUT- THE WAY
WE ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH TITLE
TWENTY FOUR IS THROUGH THE
BUILDING PERMIT AND BUILDING
INSPECTION PROCESS UNFORTUNATELY
WE'VE BEEN GRAPPLING WITH THIS
ISSUE FOR OVER A DECADE. UPWARDS
OF 90% OF THE- H. RACK
INSTALLATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
CIRCUMVENT THE PERMITTING
PROCESS THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO TRY TO CREATE A
REGISTRY SO WE CAN ENSURE THAT
TITLE TWENTY FOURS ENFORCED. AND
WE ACTUALLY GET THE ENERGY
SAVINGS THAT YOU ALL HAVE-
SOUGHT THROUGH- MANY MANY VERY
FINE PIECES OF LEGISLATION SO WE
WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU OUR NEXT SPEAKER IS THOMAS
AND- AND SLOW. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN STATES ACCOUNTS OF SHEET
METAL WORKERS. IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO
ADDRESS TWO RELATED PROBLEMS
LACK OF PERMIT COMPLIANCE AND
THEN A LACK OF ENFORCEMENT EVEN
WHEN PERMITS ARE PULLED- THE-
ENERGY COMMISSION JUST HAD A
WORKSHOP LAST WEEK ON PERMIT
COMPLIANCE IN WHICH- A BUILDING
OFFICIALS TESTIFIED THAT. ENERGY
CODE COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR
LOWEST PRIORITY AND MANY OF THEM
DO NOT EVEN LOOK AT THE TITLE
TWENTY FOUR COMPLIANCE
DOCUMENTATION BECAUSE IT'S TOO
BURDENSOME. THIS PROPOSAL WILL
ARE GREAT- SYSTEMS THAT WILL
BOTH IMPROVE COMPLIANCE AND
SIMPLIFY ENFORCEMENT. REQUIRES
TWO RELATED REPORTS OF FOUR FOUR
PLANS ONE WILL PROPOSE A PLAN
FOR TOTAL TWENTY FOUR ENERGY
CODE COMPLIANCE DOCUMENTATION
REGISTRY. THAT MAKES US ABOUT A
BUILDING OFFICIALS SO THEY CAN
SIMPLY RIGHT IN THE ADDRESS OF
THE BUILDING THAT THEIR-
INSPECTION AND GET VERIFICATION
THAT ALL OF THE TOTAL TWENTY
FOUR ACCEPTANCE TESTINGS IN
COMPLIANCE. THE DOCUMENTS
INSTALLATION. DOCUMENTS HAVE
BEEN. CREDIT AND SOME CORRECT.
AND THIS HELP US CREATE-
COMPLIANCE EVEN THOSE
JURISDICTIONS THAT CURRENT LOOK
AT ANY CODE AND- AS LOWEST PER
CASH. AT ALL. ALLOWS US TO AND
THAT- COMPLIANCE WITH PERMITS BY
HAVING AN EXPECTED SALES
REGISTER DOWN THE LINK TO THIS
TOWN TWENTY FOUR COMPLIANCE
DOCUMENTATION REGISTRY YOU CAN
TELL IF SOMEONE BOUGHT. WOMEN
AND LATER ON NEVER GETS PUT INTO
THE SYSTEM AS ACTUALLY HAVING
COMPLIED WITH THE PERMIT AND
TITLE TWENTY FOUR COMPLIANCE
DOCUMENTS WE CAN NOW ACTUALLY.
FIND THAT OUT IN FORCE IT GIVES
HIS ALL BE A TOOL TO ACTUALLY
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
WE'RE NOW WE HAVE 90% OF- H.
BACK RECORDS FOR EXAMPLE NOT
BEING PERMITTED ENOUGH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW WILL GO TO
SPEAKERS THAT ARE IN. SUPPORT OF
THE BILL HERE IN THE GALLERY
ANYONE. OKAY WE'LL GO TO THE
MODERATOR ASKED SUPPORTERS OF
THE BILL. OF FROM PEOPLE ON THE
TELEPHONE LINES MODERATOR. ITEM
NUMBER FOR SB ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AND TO BE ALIVE
AND SIXTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU AGAIN MR TURN NUMBER
THINK YOU TO KARATE WITH ENERGY
ECOLOGY SUPPORTIVE SB ELEVEN
SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER. THANK YOU IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR AN
EXCELLENT.
WE DO HAVE ONE MORE COMMENT
THANK YOU IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT. FIVE EIGHTEEN CRITICAL I
HAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN
MEMBERS BREGER TEN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE. I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU
OKAY WILL COME TO ARE THERE ARE
NO ORGANIZED PRESENTERS IN
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY OF
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
THE GALLERY. THIS IS ITEM FOR SB
ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MODERATORS PLEASE PLEASE
Q. SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION ITEM
FOR SB ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR. THEY
MUST LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. ON THE MEASURE. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO ACT BE ALIVE AND
SIX BEFORE PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THE END OF THE ROW AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU
OKAY WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE IF THERE ARE ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS. OR
MOTIONS. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR RUBIO. OF ANYONE ELSE
CENSURED YOU WANNA MAKE SOME
CLOSING COMMENTS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL VERY WELL CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AND- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ENVIRONMENT QUALITY. SB ELEVEN
SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR STERN DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY WESSEL BY
WESSEL BY DOLLY. BAKER BAKER I
FORGES ON FORAGES I BRADFORD.
DODD DODD I EGGMAN. GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE. MAN MAN I
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE STERN STERN I.
WE SALLY DOLLY I. TEN DAYS- TEN
ZERO YES NO WAY SOUNDS LIKE YOU
SAY EIGHT OR TEN AS WITH AN ACE
OKAY- SO THAT'S TEN VOTES IN
FAVOR- WILL HOLD THE ROLE
CONTRAPTION MEMBERS SENATOR YOU
HAVE ANOTHER BILL ITEM NUMBER
FIVE S. B. TWELVE SIXTY ONE
RELATING TO ENERGY ASSISTANCE
BOB AGAIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND BEFORE I BEGIN I JUST
WANNA SAY AT THE OUTSET
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S WORK
ON THE LEGISLATION- ONE EXCEPT
THE AGREED UPON COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. THAT WERE I WORKED
OUT YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
AND SHARED WITH THE FULL
COMMITTEE HAVE A GET INTO THOSE
DETAILS- AT YOUR DISCRETION-
MISTER CHAIR- BUT- IN SHORT THIS
BILL IS DEALING WITH. THE TIP OF
THE SPEAR FOR A CLIMATE
EMERGENCY WHICH- IN MANY CASES
PEOPLE THINK IS WILD FIRE FLOOD
OR SEA LEVEL RISE BUT HE- HE IS
THE GREAT SECRET KILLER IN
CALIFORNIA- TO TRACK THE-
IMPACTS OF HE- WHEN YOU HAVE A
120 DEGREES DAY. WHAT HAPPENS TO
BE ONE THEIR CONDITIONING UNIT
ISN'T WORKING. OUT WHEN YOU HAVE
A FEW WHEN YOU CAN'T COOL OFF AT
NIGHT WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
ELDERLY OR PEOPLE WITH HEART
CONDITIONS ARE EXPECTANT
MOTHERS- THIS IS THE CHALLENGE
WE'RE FACING IN CALIFORNIA. AS
WE GO THROUGH A GREAT TRYING.
ACCORDING TO GOVERNOR'S TRACKED
EXTREME HEAT REPORT WE'RE GONNA
SEE- INCREASES OF UP TO FIVE SIX
DEGREES FOR EIGHT AVERAGE DAILY
MAX TEMPERATURE I'M THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY THAT COULD BEING
APPROACHING THE ONE THIRTY RANGE
IN OUR LIFETIME. HARD TO IMAGINE
BUT WE THINK WE NEED TO TACKLE
THIS AND WE THINK THIS BILL IS A
CRITICAL PART OF IT- WILL
INVESTIGATE THIS ISSUE WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING AT A LOT OF
SOLUTIONS TO EXTREME HEAT. BUT
BUT THIS BILL REALLY TACKLES THE
BUILDING PORTION OF IT WE'RE
LOOKING AT RETROFITS INCENTIVES
TO HELP LOW INCOME FAMILIES
RETROFIT THEIR H. FAQ UNITS TO
ALLOW A COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS AND
INDUSTRIAL USERS- TO INSTALL NEW
EFFICIENT APPLIANCES AND PUMPS-
AND WE THINK HAVING LATER PUT
THEIR- THEIR FOOT PRINT ON THIS
WORK I REALLY MATTERS AND TO
THAT EXTENT I APPRECIATE THAT
THE COMMITTEES TARGETING- WE'RE
LOOKING AT LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
IN PARTICULAR- MORE PUBLIC
PROCESS IN THAT REGARD-
EXPLICITLY TALK ABOUT THE ROLE
OF ELECTRIC HEAT PUMPS. AMONG
THE MEASURES ARE TO BE FOCUSED
ON HERE I'LL CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE ENERGY COMMISSION
RESOURCE AGENCY AND OF COURSE
THIS COMMITTEE AND YOU ALL
MEMBERS- TO DEVELOP THIS
LEGISLATION WITH ME TESTIFYING
REMOTELY YEARS MARRIED FOR
JUSTIN WITH NRDC RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU AND JUST TO
OF- POINT OUT THAT WE HAVE.
SPEAK ORGANIZED A PRESENTATION
HERE WE HAVE A MERRY A MORTGAGE
SEN. AND SHE HAS THREE MINUTES
AND THERE IS NO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION SO THE CLOCK BEGINS
NOW. THANK YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARE HUESO AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS VERY
IMPORTANT I'M A SENIOR SCIENTIST
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL. I KNOW THAT
MANY OF YOU ON THE COMMITTEE ARE
LIKE SENATOR STERN DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
INCREASINGLY EXTREME HEAT OUR
COMMUNITY THINK CALIFORNIA. I DO
KNOW THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE AND TO
COMPARE FOR THE IMPACT THAT
WE'RE ALREADY SEEING. IN
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL WOULD DO
BOTH OF THOSE THINGS AS WELL THE
DRAFT INCOME AND HOUSING THE
FERRY FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
EXTREME HEAT. THE BILL PROPOSES
A PROGRAM THAT COMBINES MEASURES
THAT WOULD REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THROUGH ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND CONSERVATION
ALONG WITH PROVIDING EFFICIENT
COOLING AND OTHER MEASURES TO
IMPROVE THE COMFORT OF HOME.
ENERGY HE LOOKS FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE SENATOR TO
FURTHER DEVELOP THIS BILL AND TO
INSURE THE BEST PROGRAM
COMPLEMENT OTHER EXISTING STATE
PROGRAM. THAT INCLUDES DIRECT
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND
CORPORATE IT PROTECTION I'M INTO
THAT THE PROGRAM. WE ENCOURAGE
HER AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL TODAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU. DO
WE HAVE ANYBODY HERE THAT. WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF THE
BILL HERE IN THE- AND- THE TEST
TO- IF YOU COULD PLEASE LET ME
YOUR COMMENT TO NAME AFFILIATION
. MEASURE NOBODY IS STEPPING UP
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
SPEAKERS. IN SUPPORT. OF ITEM
FIVE S. B. TWELVE SIXTY ONE
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE THE
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. AT TWELVE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE SEVEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. NINE THIRTY SEVEN-
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SANTIAGO
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU OKAY
WE'LL GO TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO OF THEIR
THERE'S NO ORGANIZED
PRESENTATION OPPOSITION WILL GO
TO THE GALLERY FOR ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION A POSITION ON THE
MEASURE ANYONE NO ONE STEPPING
UP. WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF ITEM FIVE SB.
TWELVE SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO ASK B. TWELVE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY
WILL COME TO THE COMMITTEE NOW
AND JUSTICE YOU KNOW I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR. OF FOR
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE PUT. OUR
STAMP- AS THE LEGISLATURE BEFORE
WE SEND THIS TO THE GOVERNOR WE
HAVE AN ENORMOUS OPPORTUNITY. TO
CREATE SOME OF THE DIRECTION
FOR- FOR OUR AGENCIES-
ESPECIALLY THE CVC WHO'S ALREADY
STARTED A PROGRAM THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO WAY ENDS SO THANK
YOU FOR ACCEPTING THOSE
AMENDMENTS. YOU KNOW THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT TO MY DISTRICT
BECAUSE I HAVE- PORTIONS OF MY
DISTRICT GEOGRAPHICALLY THAT.
ARE LOCATED WITHIN- SOME. AREAS
GEOGRAPHICALLY THAT- FACE
EXTREME WEATHER SO I HAVE
MOUNTAINS WHICH OFTEN GET VERY
COLD AND I HAVE THE DESERT'S
WHICH- ARE US SOME OF THE
HOTTEST LOCATIONS IN THE WORLD
SO. THESE THESE I OFTEN ASK. YOU
KNOW WHEN WE'RE WHEN IN THE
SUMMER WHEN WE'RE RUNNING ALL
THE H. C. WHAT IS THE IMPACT TO
THE ENVIRONMENT OF ALL THAT.
THERE IS AN ENORMOUS IMPACT AND
CAN WE MITIGATE THAT AND REDUCE
THAT AND STILL UP PROVIDE.
LIVABLE ENVIRONMENTS FOR PEOPLE
THAT SOMETIMES NEED TO LIVE. IN
THESE EXTREME WEATHER CONDITIONS
YES SO- THIS IS A GREAT BILL. I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
ON THIS BILL BUT I DO. THINK
THAT- I THINK YOU KNOW WE NEED
TO WORK ON- CREATING SOME
GUIDANCE. TO THE CDC IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON THIS SO. I
LOOK FOR YOU KNOW THESE ARE OUR
INITIAL RECOMMENDATIONS AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN WORK ON. BUT
PROVIDING MORE AND I KNOW YOU'RE
GOING TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
AND THEY'LL BE PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE INPUT I'M
SURE. THAT THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN SO- DID YOU WANNA MAKE
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS MISTER
CHAIR AND- YOU KNOW THIS BILL
NEEDS TO WORK FOR COACHELLA
VALLEY NEEDS TO WORK FOR. FOR
YOU KNOW DEEP INTO THE SOUTH SAN
DIEGO NEEDS TO WORK FOR THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND EASY EXTREME
HEAT ZONES THIS IS A GREAT IN
EQUITY SO I HOPE THAT WITH THIS
INCENTIVE. AND THIS KIND OF
STRUCTURE THAT WE CAN REALLY
TARGET PEOPLE WITH THE MOST
VULNERABLE NEED. I WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. CLOSER
RUBIO DID YOU WANT TO SPEAK ON.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I
JUST WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
ALSO APPRECIATE- ADDRESSING SOME
OF THE ISSUES RAISED ON PAGE
FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS AND I HAVE
A COMPLIMENTARY BILL SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THIS AND I'D LIKE TO
MOVE OF. THE BILL WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE YEAH THAT'S A MOTION
WILL TAKE THE MOTION. CLERK OF
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND THE
MOTION IS EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS.
TO PASS AS AMENDED IN NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER. SB TWELVE
SIXTY ONE BY SENATOR STERN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
NATURAL RESOURCES ON WATER.
WESSEL FIVE WESSEL I DOLLY.
BAKER BAKER I FORGES. BRADFORD.
DODD I DON I EGGMAN. GONZALEZ I
GONZALEZ I GROSS. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG I MCGUIRE. MAN HI MAN
I RUBIO. RUBIO I STERN STERN I.
SURE THAT'S EIGHT AS. OKAY EIGHT
EIGHT VOTES IN FAVOR OF WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS AND WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX WHICH IS THE FINAL
BILL ON OUR AGENDA TODAY SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR BY CENTER
HERTZBERG. BILL RELATING TO
RESOURCE ADEQUACY REQUIREMENTS
FOR ELECTRICITY. THANK YOU
SURCHARGE FOR FIRST LIKE TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS. AS SET
FORTH IN THE ANALYSIS. THANK.
GET THAT MR YES OKAY THANK YOU
I'M- YOU KNOW ONE. START JUST
VERY BRIEFLY BECAUSE I LEFT
GOVERNMENT FOR TWELVE YEARS WERE
TRAVELING THE WORLD WORKING IN.
THE AREA OF ENVIRONMENT IN CLEAN
TECH ALL OVER THE PLANET ONE OF
THE REASONS I CAME BACK TO
GOVERNMENT WAS TO WORK ON THE
DETAILS THAT AREN'T THE HEADLINE
GRABBING DETAILS THAT PUT ALL
THESE GREAT NUMBERS OUT THERE IN
THESE GREAT. GOALS AND LOFTY
GOALS BUT TO DEAL WITH THE
DETAILS TO ACTUALLY DEAL WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE TO DEAL WITH THE
KINDS OF CHANGES THAT WE HAVE TO
MAKE TO MAKE THE SYSTEM WORK SO
ALTHOUGH THIS IS ONE OF THE
LEAST ATTENTION GRABBING BILLS I
WOULD SUGGEST. IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT. CALIFORNIA IS
FACING AS WE KNOW AND PRESIDENT
NEED FOR RENEWABLE ENERGY
RESOURCES. TO POWER THE STATE'S
ELECTRIC IT OVER THE NEXT TWO
DECADES. SB ONE HUNDRED GOALS
ARE PS REQUIREMENTS WHICH WE DID
WHEN I WAS SPEAKER CONSUMER
DEMANDS. FOR CLEAN ENERGY AND
RAPID TRANSPORTATION LIKE TO
VACATION. ALL CALL FOR A TOTAL
TRANSFORMATION OF OUR ENTIRE
ELECTRIC SECTOR. A NEW DEAL A
NEW DEAL FOR ELECTRIC GOOD IF
YOU WILL. GET ALL OVER AMBITIOUS
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS ARE NOTHING
NOTHING MORE THAN GOALS WITHOUT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE. TO DELIVER
THAT CLEAN POWER. CALIFORNIA NOT
ONLY NEEDS MORE CLEAN POWER WE
NEED A MODERN TRANSMISSION
SYSTEM THAT CAN ACTUALLY DELIVER
IT TO EVERY COMMUNITY ACROSS THE
STATE. WE'VE ALREADY EXPERIENCE
WHAT CAN HAPPEN WHEN OUR GREAT
IS NOT EQUIPPED TO MEET THAT
DEMAND. THE ROTATING ALLERGIES
THE LAST FEW YEARS REVEALED
SIGNIFICANT VULNERABILITIES IN A
RELIABILITY OF OUR ELECTRICAL
SUPPLY. ANY PROLONGED FREQUENT
OR UNPLANNED INTERRUPTION WILL
CREATE A BACKLASH AMONG
CUSTOMERS AND PUT THE ENTIRE THE
ENTIRETY OF OUR CLIMATE GOALS AT
RISK POLITICALLY. SO WE NEED TO
GET TO WORK SHORTFALLS IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING AND
EXECUTION IS OUR BIGGEST BURIED
REPLACING FOSSIL FUEL RESOURCES
CURRENTLY MAINTAINING THE
SYSTEM'S RELIABILITY. IN THE
NEAR TERM MEMBERS MANY
TRANSMISSION PROJECTS WE NEED TO
MEET OUR CAPACITY NOW FACE THE
COST RATHER THAN FACE COSTLY
SETBACKS WITH NO REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY ACCOUNTABILITY OR
OVERSIGHT BY OUR STATE. IN THE
LONG TERM WE NEED TO GET OUT OF
THE- JUST IN TIME CYCLE OF
PROCUREMENT TRANSPORTATION SHE'S
ME AND TRANSMISSION BUILD OUT WE
MUST ESTABLISH A ROBUST PROCESS
FOR LONG TERM LEAD RESOURCES
WHICH TAKES EIGHT TO TEN YEARS
TO COMPLETE I REPEAT. EIGHT TO
TEN YEARS TO COMPLETE THE SAID
THE APPROPRIATE MARKET SIGNALS
TO ENSURE RELIABILITY MOVING
FORWARD THIS MEASURE SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR WILL CONNECT THE
STATE'S BOLD PLANNING PLANS FOR
ELECTRIFYING OUR ECONOMY WITH
COMMONSENSE POLICIES. RAMPING UP
CLEAN ENERGY AND MODERN
INFRASTRUCTURE REQUIRED TO POWER
A CLEANER GREENER CALIFORNIA. TO
WITNESSES TESTIFYING TODAY
MICHAEL COLVIN FROM THE
ENVIRONMENT DEFENSE FUND AND
CAMERON. YOUR KASKI FROM THE EDP
RENEWABLES WILL START OUT WITH
MICHAEL COLEMAN. OKAY WE'RE
GONNA HAVE THAT BEGIN WITH
MICHAEL COLEMAN AND EACH SPEAKER
HAS A MINUTE AND A HALF. AND SO-
MICHAEL COLEMAN YOU'RE ON THE
CLOCK. I THANK YOU SHARE I HELLO
MEMBERS AGAIN MY NAME IS MICHAEL
COLEMAN BERMAN. ON AIRING
SUPPORT BUT I FEEL THIRTY FOUR
AM I REALLY THE FACT ABOUT THE
NEED FOR MORE TRANSMISSION
PLANNING I'M NOW TURNING OUR
ATTENTION TO CLEARING THE
BACKLOG OF THAT TRANSITION Q.
AND I'M PRETTY CLEAR IN ANY
PROPOSED TO BE TRANSITION BUILT
ON THAT DAY AND I URGE YOU TO
THINK OF THEM AS- BOTH OF THEM.
AT ALL. THE REASON WHY I.
BACKLOG THAT. AND HE CAN'T
MANAGE ABOUT AND I. HELLO THE
EVEN HE FOUND IS TAKING INTERNET
THAT. REPORT TO DO ALTHOUGH TO
HELP CLEAR THE BACKLOG. PETER
EQUITABLE AND MANNER. I WONDER
IF I LIKE THE NEW FOR THE RIVER
FROM IN THE BILL HER NAME OR ANY
THAT IS CAN TO REQUIRE IN I
THINK WHAT CONDITION WILL BE A
AND ONE OF READY. THE MORE
INFORMATION ARE TO THE DECISION
. IN MAKING THE RIGHT I NEED A-
TO HELP YOU GREAT. AND
REASONABLE. MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THE LANGUAGE CONCERNING REQUEST
AT PROGRAM. WE'LL BE RIGHT AND
REPORTER MY HAPPEN TO THEM ARE
ABLE IN NOT CAUGHT UP IN ALL OF
THE TRANSMISSION ISSUE OVER.
THIS IS REAL PROBLEM INITIATIVE
BE IGNORE IT BECAUSE IS THANK
OUR THE TECHNICIAN WAS.
ENCOURAGED ME AUTHORED WORK WITH
THE DAY. TO FIND COMPROMISE WHEN
IT COMES THAT. ACCOUNTING FOR
ADEQUATELY. AND REFINED THE
FINDINGS WERE. APPROACH WHEN BAD
I SUPPORT THE BILL AND I ASK
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU- WE'LL
GO TO THIS SPEAK IN SOME. OF
CAMERA. KASKY YOU'RE ON THE
CLOCK. YES GOOD AT MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE CAN. MY NAME IS
CAMERON CALCULATE WORK FOR EDP
RENEWABLE DPR SUPPORT SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR BECAUSE IT HELPS TO
ADDRESS THE TRANSMISSION
INTERCONNECTION DELAYS SPARKLING
REQUIRES YOU PROJECTS IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY. SAMPLE GARSIDE
INTERCONNECTION AGREEMENT IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN LISTING SIX
SMALL UPGRADES TO BE COMPLETED
IN THIRTY MONTHS WE THEN ENTERED
INTO CONTRACTS WITH CALIFORNIA
BOTH SERVING ENTITIES. REVIVED
RESOURCE ADEQUACY STARTING IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE SOME
SUBSEQUENTLY FOUND OUT IN TWENTY
TWENTY THAN THE TRANSMISSION
UPGRADES WERE DELAYED BY SIX
YEARS. OLD WILL HELP TO AVOID
SIMILAR CIRCUMSTANCES IN THE
FUTURE BY IMPROVING THE
TRANSPARENCY REPORTING THE
PRIORITIZATION AND ALSO AGENCY
COORDINATION- SURROUNDING
TRANSMISSION UPGRADES IN
ADDITION THE SPELL- DOES SIX
SITUATION THAT TODAY WERE THE
RING ENTITIES IN AMERICA WINNERS
. PARKING LOT THE TRANSMISSION
AWAITS THAT THEY HAVE NO CONTROL
OVER AND ACTING THE WAIVER
PROVISION BANNER STAND MAY BE.
CONSIDERED TO BE TAKEN OUT WOULD
NOT IMPACT RELIABILITY THE
TRANSMISSION DELAY FROM CELLS
ARE REAL THREATS TO RELIABILITY
AND PENALIZING ALLERGIES OR
SOMETHING THAT BY TODAY NOR US
THEIR SUPPLIERS TO CONTROL DOES
NOTHING TO IMPROVE RELIABILITY.
TRANSACTION IF THE PENALTIES ARE
MAINTAINS DEVELOPERS WILL HAVE
TO PRICE IN THE REST OF THOSE
PENALTIES AND DAMAGES INTO THEIR
POWER PURCHASE AGREEMENTS. AND
WILL DELAY SIGNING CONTRACTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR THE
CURRENT ONLY STRUCTURE. THE YOU
BYE SHOULD COMMENTS THE ENERGY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHARING YOUR
COMMON. OKAY WE'LL GO TO SPEAKER
IN SUPPORT HERE IN THE- LIMIT
YOUR COMMENTS TO. YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JOHN WHITE WITH THE
CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE I DON'T SEE ANYONE
ELSE. WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN WE WROTE AT THE TIME. WE'LL
START WITH LINE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO ANASTASIA KAMAL
CHECK ON BEHALF OF SOLAR ENERGY
INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION AND LARGE
SCALE SOLAR ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
BAKER. THANK YOU I AM SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE PHILADELPHIA CREAM ON
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY STORAGE
ALLIANCE AT THE PORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. THANK YOU
I'M THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THIS IS SANTIAGO CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL LITERACY CALLING
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU. VERY
GOOD- WILL COME TO NOW SPEAKERS
INOPPOSITION THERE'S NO
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION I SEE NO
ONE HERE IN THE GALLERY
MODERATOR CAN YOU GO TO SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION OF ITEM NUMBER SIX
S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO ASK THE ALIVE AND
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. IT'LL BE
ONE MOMENT FOR OUR FIRST COMMENT. BY SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS NIKOLINA AND THEN THIS
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR
MANY OF GAS AND ELECTRIC AND
THAT WE WERE OPPOSED TO LOOK
AMENDED BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
MAIN CONCERNS WOULD BE ADDRESSED
WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR IN
THE COMMITTEE AND REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION FROM THE BILL AND WE
DO NOT TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR ALSO TO PROTECT THE
TECHNICAL ISSUE WITH THE HELP OF
TO COMPLY WITH THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THE BILL. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND- WE WOULD LIKE
TO REMOVE OUR POSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HELPFUL
COMMENTS. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU. OKAY
VERY WELL WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- FOR DISCUSSION OR A
MOTION. THE MOTION. THAT YOU ARE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. AND THERE
REALLY IS ONE OF MINOR AMENDMENT
AND APPRECIATE YOU ACCEPTING
AMENDMENT- DID YOU WANT TO MAKE
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS THANKS VERY
MUCH FOR SURE THANKS TO STAFF
FOR WORKING TOGETHER AND LOOK
FORWARD FOR THIS A NEW DEAL FOR
THE- ELECTRIC GRID TO ACTUALLY
MAKE ALL OF OUR EFFORTS WORK
THANK YOU ASTRONOMICAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF SO CLICK PLEASE
CALL. THE ROLL TO PASS AS MANY
FOR PATIENTS THIS CALL THE ROLL
. SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG D. PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL
I WAS SO BY DOLLY. BAKER BAKER I
FORGES. BRADFORD DODD ALL RIGHT
DODD AYE EGGMAN. GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG ALL
RIGHT HERTZBERG BY MCGUIRE. MAN
MAN HI RUBIO. RUBIO HI STERN.
STERN I. THAT'S EIGHT AS CHAIR
OKAY VERY WELL WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THAT BRINGS US TO THE CONCLUSION
OF TODAY'S MEETING WORK ON A ASK
ABSENT MEMBERS COME BACK TO THE
SENATE FLOOR TODAY AT ALL. TO
THE BILLS WE WILL PROVIDE. WILL
BE HERE AN ADDITIONAL TEN
MINUTES. LET SUFFER THE MEMBERS
THAT ARE HERE- CLERK AT LEAST
BACK OVER THE ROLE. AND IF YOU
CAN IDENTIFY THOSE BILLS IN
WHICH- THIRD BOB WAS NOT ADDED
SB THIRTY NINETY THREE BY
SENATOR I TO LET THAT DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE. DODD DODD I. THAT'S AS
CHAIR WHEN THERE'S A LITTLE SOME
NUMBERS MISSING VERY GOOD OKAY
WILL CALL THE ROLL CONTRAPTION
MEMBERS. DO WE HAVE ANY COMING
BACK.
DATA CENTER READ FOR IS NOT A
BEGINNING WITH ITEM NUMBER SIX
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR BY
HERTZBERG. CLARK PLEASE CALL. SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD. REDFORD
I WILL GO TO AN ITEM NUMBER FIVE
S. B. 1261% OR STERN SB TWELVE
SIXTY ONE BY SENATOR STERN DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER BRADFORD
WHICH WILL COME. OKAY WHAT'S THE
VOTE COUNT EIGHT AS HI. BRADFORD
I NINE AS. OKAY WE'LL GO TO ITEM
NUMBER FOUR WHAT'S OF O'CONNOR
NATIVE NUMBER FOUR. TEN AS. ITEM
NUMBER FOUR ELEVEN SB ELEVEN
SIXTY FOUR WITH REFERENCE. I'LL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. SB
ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR
STERN TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ENVIRONMENT QUALITY BRADFORD AYE
BRADFORD AYE THAT'S ELEVEN
EASTER. OKAY ON ITEM NUMBER
THREE S. B. EIGHT SEVEN BY
SENATOR BAKER. THIS CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SB EIGHT EIGHT
SEVEN BY SENATOR RECORD TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
BRADFORD. HI BRADFORD I. OKAY AS
OF ARCHER. DID YOU VOTE ON ONE
INTO A VOTED ON ONE NOT TOO FAR
IT WILL GO TO NUMBER TWO SB
EIGHT EIGHT ONE BY SENATOR MEN.
SB EIGHT. EIGHT ONE BY SENATOR
MAN TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
BRADFORD. NOBODY. THAT'S AS
CHAIR. OKAY WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OF THE PRESS MEMBERS.
WHAT. GET EVERYTHING.
WE'RE BACK HERE A TWO I DON'T
ABSENT MEMBERS. AND WE'RE GOING
TO BEGIN WITH ITEM NUMBER TWO S.
B. EIGHT EIGHT ONE BY SENATOR
MEN CLERK PLEASE CALL THE UPS
MEMBERS. SB EIGHT ONE BY SENATOR
MANDY PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
DOLLY GORGEOUS. BRADFORD GROVE.
MCGUIRE STERN. WE'LL GO TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB EIGHT EIGHT
SEVEN BY SENATOR BECKER. SB
EIGHT SEVEN BY SEVEN A BACKER
DAY PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. GROW MCGUIRE HI
MCGUIRE HI THE THIRTEEN EASTER.
BURGER ITEM NUMBER OF THE SO-
THAT WE SEE HERE JUST TO RECAP
ON ITEM NUMBER ONE WHAT IS THE
FINAL VOTE. EIGHT AS AND TO
KNOWS BAIT AS INTERNOS ON SB
THIRTY NINETY THREE WILL CLOSED
THE ROLE OF NOT BILL. SB EIGHT
EIGHT ONE WHAT'S THE FINAL VOTE
COUNT. EIGHT AS- THAT'S A. EIGHT
AS OUR- OF THE BILL IS OUT WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE ON SB EIGHTY ONE
ON S. B. EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN ITEM
NUMBER THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. EIGHT EIGHT SB
EIGHT SEVEN BY SEVEN A RECORD TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. GROW. THIRTEEN A
STIR OKAY THIRTEEN AS A BILL IS
OUT ITEM NUMBER FOUR. SB ELEVEN
SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR STERN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SB ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR
STERN DEPRESSED AS AMENDED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. EGGMAN
GROW. MCGUIRE BYE MCGUIRE AYE
THAT'S TWELVE A STIR TWELVE AS
ON S. B. ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR WILL
CLOSE ROLE WILL GO TO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE S. B. TWELVE SIXTY
ONE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SB TWELVE SIXTY ONE BY
SENATOR STERN TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER.
DOLLY FORTUS. EGGMAN GROWTH
MCGUIRE BY MCGUIRE I. TEN A STIR
TURN AS THE BILL IS ABOUT WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE WILL GO TO. I
DON'T NUMBER SIX SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR BY CENTER HERTZBERG
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AND CLERK. SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR BY SENATOR HERTZBERG D.
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. DOLLY BARGES
EGGMAN. HERTZBERG. I'M SORRY
HERTZBERG WAS IN A COLLEGES
REQUIRE REQUIRE I. OKAY HOW MANY
VOTES ELEVEN DAYS ELEVEN IS.
SANDEL B. ELEVEN EYES WILL CLOSE
ROLE THAT BRING US THE END OF
OUR CALENDAR TODAY I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION IF YES HI
APOLOGIES THERE'S A- N. A.'S ON
IT SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR.
TORNADOES ON ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
OKAY LET'S MAKE THE CORRECTION
ITEM SIX SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
GETS OUT WHAT TEN AS IN.
ATTENDANCE IN FAVOR FOR PHYLLIS
OUT ALL THE BILLS ARE OUT TODAY.
SO WE WILL MOVE FORWARD- I WANT
TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION TESTAMENT MONEY
TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFIED TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED.
THE AGENDA.